nous avons une tradition qui normalement
démarrage à l'heure avec une contrainte
que je vous prie de nous pardonner
puisqu'il y a projet de loi de finance
encore ce matin il y a une commission
mixte paritaire
donc on a des collègues qui vont nous
rejoindre au fur et à mesure en tout cas
je voulais vous dire le plaisir
qui est le mien et que mon collègueré
mes cointro qui est le premier
vice-président de la délégation
et celui qui porte la mission on va dire
de simplification combien nous sommes
vraiment heureux de vous de vous
rencontrer parce que
cette simplification ou cette chatte aux
normes dirait Alain lombaire fait partie
de la mission qui est celle de la de la
délégation et que par ailleurs le
président du Sénat a lancé récemment un
nouveau groupe de travers je dis
œcuménique il réunit tous les groupes
politiques du Sénat sur un peu dans la
prolongation de ce qui avait été fait en
2020 et qui avait abouti au 50
propositions en faveur des libertés
locales c'est-à-dire comment permettre
de gagner des points en efficacité de
l'action publique jusqu'au dernier
kilomètre et vous en parler très souvent
par
ces outils que sont la décentralisation
la déconcentration mais aussi
la simplification et je vous disais hier
en loi de finance l'exemple qu'on a
encore eu d'une comment dire d'un rajout
dans la loi qui ne correspond moins à
une norme et qui ne rajoute rien sinon à
compliqué à compliquer voilà donc
monsieur le vice-président du Conseil
d'État vraiment merci de prendre le
temps de venir nous rencontrer Madame la
Présidente la section du rapport et des
études merci à vous d'être là et de
poursuivre la conversation que nous
avions initiés grâce à vous et Alain
Lambert
chez vous très récemment Monsieur
Patrick Gérard qui est président adjoint
la section Administration alors nous le
disons nous le disions vous êtes un
habitué de cette maison et vous êtes
sans doute celui qui parmi nous a
peut-être déjà
comment dire beaucoup progressé dans les
7 vies que certains croient que nous
avons puisque ici vous êtes venu avec
vos fonctions très différentes et ça
toujours été un grand plaisir de vous
accueillir monsieur Girardot qui est le
secrétaire général merci à vous et
Monsieur Desprez qui est chargé de
mission auprès du vice-président donc
vraiment l'importance de votre
délégation
nous honneurs donc je rappelais que nous
avions de plaisir de recevoir votre
prédécesseur monsieur le Président
l'audition plénière c'était en mars
2021 Monsieur Bruno Lasserre et je qu'on
appelle le plaisir de nous rencontrer
successives et nous avions évoqué à
l'époque avec vous l'importance de la
formation des hauts fonctionnaires aux
enjeux de simplification mais je me
permettrai avec beaucoup d'humilité de
dire qu'il y a le même enjeu à former
les parlementaires que nous sommes qui
péchons parfois par excès ou par manque
de confiance
dans nos collègues dans nos collègues et
le locaux et nous avions également à vos
côtés monsieur Perinet qui est le
directeur de l'Institut national des
études territoriales et nous avons
souhaité
apporter notre contribution à ce
dialogue et à cette formation puisque
nous accueillons cette année des
stagiaires de lunettes qui travaillent
ici
pour la pour notre délégation d'une
manière assez remarquable et ce dialogue
est très situation pour que nos cultures
réciproques soient plus poreuse et se
fertilise davantage et donc nous avons
également reçu il y a deux semaines
Monsieur Charles de Gaulle qui est
rapportant des études du Conseil d'État
2016 et 2018 donc voilà nous avons
ensemble aujourd'hui une proximité de de
la préoccupation nous savons monsieur le
Président que vous partagiez ou vous
partageons cette passion pour ceux qui
devrait être une obligation l'efficacité
de l'action publique et le colloque que
vous avez organisé donc le 14 octobre
dernier
avec le CNE et le président lombaire
l'illustrait totalement puis vous nous
parlerez sans doute de vos intentions et
de vos projets mais la difficulté à
laquelle nous sommes confrontés c'est
une énigme c'est-à-dire chaque acteur ou
chaque contributeur à l'action publique
et consciente de l'enjeu et de la
nécessité consciente d'apporter sa part
et quand même temps nous ne cessons
année après année de nous désoler
de ce que l'efficacité de l'action
publique puisse encore beaucoup beaucoup
progressé donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle le président Larcher a confié
un autre délégation
ce sujet avec des interrogations très
fortes sur la fabrique de la loi et la
fabrique de la norme ce que je pense
qu'il y a une chaîne de production qui
doit être qui doit être
comment dire mieux mieux mieux mieux
maîtriser et qui permettrait d'éviter
des proliférations qui ont ceci
d'obsédant c'est que la norme qui est
faite pour permettre sécuriser et
protéger devient parfois une norme parce
que on veut trop sécuriser trop protégé
un homme qui est contre-productif c'est
à dire que elle finit par annuler toute
capacité
toute capacité d'action et je n'oserais
pas dire que parfois le contrarie
législateur ce qui peut arriver mais je
vous donnerai un exemple dans la loi 3DS
nous avons voté une disposition à partir
d'un amendement que j'avais porté qui
est la possibilité
pour des élus locaux dans un cadre
précis sur un territoire à l'échelle
d'un Scott de pouvoir réguler les
ouvertures de grandes surfaces
alimentaires le dimanche chose simple
parce qu'on m'a dit ah non mais vous
savez le Conseil d'État va exiger des
normes et va exiger des seuils je leur
ai dit sans doute qu'il y a un moment
que vous ne les avez pas rencontrés
parce que ayant eu la chance de voir je
pense que
l'intelligence de le souci de
l'efficacité sont des exercices
extrêmement extrêmement pratique au
Conseil d'État et puis dernier point que
nous avons aussi évoqué ce sont les
études d'impact
ces études d'impact qui ont vraiment été
conçus et créé pour répondre à cette
idée d'une évaluation a priori et d'une
mesure de l'efficacité et de la
pertinence des
propositions des dispositions
législatives ou des normes je pense
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes encore un peu
sur notre fin et j'ose pas dire que le
Conseil constitutionnel un peu
neutralisé puisqu'il s'assure dans son
analyse que tous les paramètres sont
bien présents d'un bac mais
peut-être devrait-il
porter plus d'attention au fond au fond
des choses alors nous interrogeons
aujourd'hui sur une proposition que vous
avez faite en 2016
sur une certification indépendante des
études d'impact afin d'apprécier leur
complétude et leur sincérité et deuxième
sujet pensez-vous que ce rêve
que cultive et
mon éminent collégrémie trop en bas en
parlera ce rêve de dire comme nous
créons une norme nous en supprimons deux
pensez-vous que cela soit possible
pensez-vous que quand on parle de ça on
parle des normes qui existent dans les
décrets mais aussi dans la loi voilà je
vous ai livré avec beaucoup de
simplicité de spontanéité voilà nos
préoccupations
Rémi Pointreau
aura certainement un certain nombre
c'est pas certainement il a un certain
nombre d'idées supplétion et en tout cas
il a une volonté d'avancer et vraiment
moi je vous redis le plaisir réel qui
est le nom de pouvoir avoir ce dialogue
avec vous pour que
on est cette capacité ensemble à faire
bouger les lignes pour plus d'efficacité
de simplicité et je pense que au-delà
de la nécessité de loi efficace c'est
simple je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
situation où l'état de la société et de
notre pays nous nous permettent guère le
luxe de l'unification c'était ma pensée
personnelle du matin
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
donc merci infiniment madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
merci et nous sommes très honorés de
pouvoir venir contribuer à votre à vos
réflexions et à vos travaux sur un sujet
auquel vous le savez vous avez
l'amabilité de le rappeler le Conseil
d'État est tout particulièrement
sensible attachés la simplification des
normes même si nous contribuons à
beaucoup de normes leur qualité la
qualité du droit c'est évidemment la
préoccupation première du Conseil d'État
dans plusieurs de ses fonctions et alors
je voudrais au prélat peut-être de vous
dire combien nous nous sommes également
heureux d'être parmi vous au titre des
relations que nous entretenons entre nos
deux institutions qui sont absolument
essentiels pour nous on se réjouit de
pouvoir
contribuer à vos travaux sur des
propositions de loi lorsque elles nous
sont soumises et en tout cas ce travail
les échanges entre les deux institutions
sont des éléments clés nous rencontrons
les commissions sont venues au Conseil
d'État pour pour que nous puissions
mieux nous nous connaître nous
comprendre et travailler dans l'objectif
que vous avez rappelé qui je crois est
tout à fait commun et ce dialogue sera
bien sûr poursuivi je suis accompagné de
plusieurs membres du conseil que vous
avez eu la gentillesse de saluer parce
que voilà nous avons une réflexion
collective au conseil sur ces questions
et je crois qu'il était important que
ceux qui ont contribué ou qui ont une
approche propre à leur fonction puisse
être ici et notamment donc Martine de
boisdev président de rapport de la
section du rapport des études et
Patricia président adjoint la section
Administration qui était le rapporteur
général d'études importantes notamment
en 2016 sur la simplification et la
qualité du droit puisque c'est un sujet
qui malheureusement reste d'actualité et
sur lequel nous continuons à réfléchir
vous nous avez communiqué informé des
pistes de travail de votre commission et
à l'occasion d'échanger sur ce point
l'ensemble des membres de la délégation
nous ne pouvons devant vous procéder à
une expertise juridique approfondie de
ces pistes parce qu'elles sont vraiment
très très
importantes profondes évidemment et bon
je ne parle pas de d'aspects politiques
qui ne nous incompnent pas mais dans les
enjeux juridiques elles sont évidemment
très très importantes en termes de
conséquences et
si nous étions consultés sur une
proposition de loi évidemment on
pourrait approfondir ces questions tout
à fait fortement je vais en à titre
linéaire peut-être vous donner quelques
éléments sur les études et les
principales conclusions du du Conseil
d'État sur ces questions et puis
terminer vous y avez fait référence même
la présidente en évoquant le projet
d'étude annuelle qui n'est pas en lien
avec les travaux que vous conduisez dans
votre assemblée et qui peut-être
pourront vous intéresser en tout cas où
vous en vous j'essaierai de vous dire
l'état d'esprit dans lequel nous nous
engageons ce travail annuel alors la
simplification est évidemment au cœur de
des travaux Conseil d'État lorsqu'on est
confronté à des projets de loi des
projets de d'ordonnance ou de décret
cette question est évidemment
revient systématiquement parce que
l'abondance des textes fait que elle
impose de ce de ce la poser et nous
sommes évidemment c'est notre mission
constitutionnelle attachée à la sécurité
juridique à l'intelligibilité de la
norme qui est pas toujours d'ailleurs sa
son raccourcissement si j'ose dire enfin
c'est une question ou sur lequel moi je
m'interroge beaucoup qu'il vaut mieux
que la norme soit limpide clair
que nécessairement très très ramassé et
puis bien évidemment la bonne
administration en particulier donc
la bonne administration des services
publics alors on s'attache depuis
longtemps à cette simplification du
droit avec des résultats qui sont
évidemment pas toujours à la hauteur de
nos de nos attentes ou de nos ambitions
mais en tout cas c'est en raison de ces
intérêts partagés que le Conseil
national d'évaluation des normes et de
conseil état ont organisé le colloque
auquel vous faisiez référence dans votre
dans votre introduction
alors l'intérêt du Conseil d'État pour
la simplification et bien antérieure à
ces travaux puisque dès l'étude de 1991
consacrée à la sécurité juridique on
avait abordé ces questions et en 2006
nous avions produit des travaux sur
sécurité juridique et complexité du
droit qui recommandait le l'imposition
des études d'impact qui ont été prévues
deux ans plus tard par la révision
cautionnelle de 2008 et la loi organique
de 2009 alors l'étude de 2016 pour
revenir aux travaux les plus récents
porte sur la simplification à la qualité
du droit et rappelle que sous l'effet de
plusieurs facteurs le droit c'est
densifier peut-être au détriment d'une
forme d'action publique en tout cas
rendu l'action publique plus complexe
mais l'étude bon envisager un certain
nombre de remèdes
d'abord elle rappelait que cette
complexité est en partie due à des
facteurs sur lesquels il est difficile
d'agir la technicité de certaines
matières qui évidemment rendent la norme
parfois un petit peu ésotérique au moins
pour ceux ne sont pas des spécialistes
de la matière l'insertion de l'économie
dans la globalisation la
constitutionnalisation leur organisation
l'internationalisation des sources du
droit qui sont évidemment des éléments
qui dans la fabrique de la norme à
laquelle vous faisiez référence
contraignent un certain nombre de
dispositions en doute la production de
normes s'auto-alimente avec la nécessité
de prendre donc bien sûr les mesures
d'application vous avez fait référence
un cas singulier pour les rendre
effectives et par ailleurs les
producteurs de normes sont on le
constate de plus en plus nombreux
dispersés comme leurs vecteurs et je
crois que dans notre réflexion en tout
cas nous y attachons beaucoup de
d'importance on est quand même frappé
par la place que prend le droit souple
avec des des constructions qui sont
également de nature plus peut-être plus
complexe que le droit positif classique
et qui dans certains secteurs
professionnels ont pris une importance
très très grande alors l'étude de 2016
désigne des pistes d'amélioration le
premier axe c'est bien sûr là la
réflexion des pouvoirs publics en
renforçant le l'impératif de
simplification qui est répétée et en
soutenant les initiatives qui visent à
renforcer les capacités d'évaluation du
du Parlement avec la question quand même
un peu lancinante des études d'impact
auquel nous attachons beaucoup
d'importance dans les avis que nous
rendons sur les projets de loi vous le
savez c'est une question qui est
systématiquement étudiée qui est
approfondie certains avis qui sont
rendus public depuis l'addition du
président de la République
sur sur les projets lois en tout cas non
financiers certains avis ont beaucoup
insisté sur la
place de l'étude d'impact éventuellement
leurs insuffisances pour inviter le
gouvernement à présenter avant le dépôt
au Parlement une étude d'impact
complétée qui soit conforme en tout cas
à nos yeux au dispositions de la loi
organique le deuxième axe de réflexion
c'est évidemment il s'impose
naturellement maîtriser l'emballement de
la production de textes avec une
maîtrise de la programmation de cette
production ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
évident et nous voyons parfois venir des
flux de textes à des moments dans le
dans l'année qui pose problème et le
recours aux ordonnances de
simplification et à la codification
puisque ça c'est quand même un élément
important de simplification de du droit
et le concepta recommande aussi le
renforcement de l'évaluation excentée en
procédant à une étude d'option afin
avant d'engager un projet de réforme et
en élargissant le champ de celle-ci
notamment éventuellement aux amendements
aux propositions de loi pour qu'on
puisse disposer de l'ensemble des
informations qui sont nécessaires au
choix qui doivent être faits avant que
l'on comment dire qu'on expertise qu'on
analyse l'option qui a été retenue
recommande également un recours plus
fréquent à l'expérimentation et le
développement de l'évaluation expote non
seulement pour en tirer des conséquences
sur la disposition mais peut-être aussi
pour en tirer des conséquences sur
d'autres dispositions qui pourraient
relever de la de la même logique en
prévoyant des clauses examen des lois et
ordonnances je précise toutefois que
l'étude de 2016 ne préconisait pas
d'instituer à titre de sanction pour
défaut ou retard d'évaluation expose une
clause guillotine entraînant la CALL
ucité du texte non évalué et reconduit
dans la mesure où on avait estimé à
l'époque ces clauses engendre un grand
insécurité juridique et contribue à
aggraver l'instabilité de la norme voire
à supprimer toute norme applicable à un
secteur ce qui pourrait d'ailleurs
parfois mettre en contradiction avec les
obligations européennes lorsque celle-ci
se se sont fixés par les directives
troisième axe visait à faciliter
l'application de la norme grâce à la
codification j'ai déjà fait référence
alors un très gros effort a été fait on
a quand même une extension des des cotes
mais qui peut encore être poursuivie et
puis la clarification des normes
applicables outre-mer ou encore le
développement des guichets uniques ou
des du dispositif du
dites-le nous une fois qui impose à
l'administration de faire le travail
travail plutôt que de l'imposer à
l'usager qui est confronté à plusieurs
plusieurs procédures le Conseil d'État
attache également une importance aux
conditions d'entrée en vigueur des
textes et qui est parfois un petit peu
délicates à apprécier donc il mérite je
crois une réflexion et sur lequel
travaille de d'analyse des textes dans
notre fonction consultative nous
consacrons beaucoup de temps ces
conditions de d'entrée en vigueur et
enfin évidemment au rôle du juge dans
son office simplificateur puisque quand
il vient interpréter le texte il était
également important qu'il ait cette
cette préoccupation en tête cette étude
a connu des suites et des prolongements
les propositions qu'elle formulées ont
été en partie continué par des travaux
récents et importants le premier porte
sur les expérimentations bien sûr qui
peuvent permettre lorsqu'elles sont
couplées à des évaluations d'identifier
des gisements de simplification
ce qui a été montré dans le dans de ce
qui a été monté à l'étude de 2019 faite
à la demande du Premier ministre et
c'est pourquoi l'étude proposait
notamment des temps des rationalisés les
dispositifs juridiques permanents
d'expérimentation ouverte c'est-à-dire
celle qui ouvre une potentialité
expérimentation au bénéfice d'adaptation
de normes qui ne sont pas définies à
l'avance quelques exemples dans sa
l'article 51 de d'une loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale sur
l'expérimentation en matière de de
d'assurance maladie qui ont donné lieu à
un certain nombre de dispositifs qui je
crois en permis de d'apprécier ces
éléments et les principaux champs
concernés de ce pour ces dispositions
sont donc la santé comme je disais
l'éducation nationale et la
réglementation s'appliquant aux
entreprises
alors sur cette ce le Conseil d'État
proposé aussi de transposer des
dispositifs au projet des collectivités
territoriales en offrant notamment la
possibilité de susciter elle-même des
expérimentations en créant par exemple
un guichet permanent qui leur
permettrait de soumettre au Parlement au
gouvernement des projets de modification
des normes régissant leur compétences
lorsque nécessité leur apparaît
la loi organique de d'avril 2021
relative à la simplification des
expérimentations mises en oeuvre sur le
fondement du quatrième et de l'article
72 de la Constitution bien sûr a permis
d'avancer dans ces expérimentations
locales avec la volonté entre autres de
créer des guichets locaux en préfecture
pour apporter aux collectivités un appui
dans leurs expérimentations et la fin du
régime d'autorisation préalable pour
entrer dans les expérimentations enfin
la loi 3DS de 2022 est une nouvelle
étape dans cette dans le cadre de cette
volonté de simplification sur le champ
disons de des expérimentations
l'évaluation sur le deuxième temps sur
laquelle a porté l'étude de 2020 et qui
était déjà recommandée en 2016 peut
également permettre de simplifier au
plus tôt de ne pas adopter des normes
qui complexifieraient le droit et je
crois que c'était fort et aussi
important que l'effort de simplification
puisqu'on voit le flux normatif qui se
poursuit sans pouvoir présenter ici
cette étude je voudrais souligner que la
qualité du droit a toujours beaucoup
gagné a beaucoup à gagner de
l'évaluation c'est ce que nous
soulignons en 2016 c'est ce que vos
travaux rappellent régulièrement les
évaluations excentées devraient par
exemple systématiquement et c'est
vraiment un point pour nous très
important déboucher je l'évoquais
rapidement sur une étude d'options
comparant les mérites du recours à un
texte avec les autres solutions
possibles l'action publique ce n'est pas
uniquement de la production de normes ça
peut passer par d'autres voix et je
crois que
y compris l'option 0 en termes de de
création de normes doit être envisagée
dans un grand nombre de cas la
simplification procédera alors d'une
réelle évaluation qui mène au choix de
légiférer ou non alors qu'il peut être
tentant de procéder à une évaluation
d'habillage ou en tout cas disons un
petit peu rapide
une fois que le choix du législateur a
déjà été arrêté c'est probablement sur
ce point fondamental que but les
obligations de renforcement du spectre
de l'évaluation car il est toujours
possible pour l'administration de
remplir formellement ces obligations et
ce sont les les remarques que l'on peut
faire sur un certain nombre d'études
d'impact que nous rencontrons
je vous souhaite souligner que le
Conseil d'État est attaché à examiné de
plus en plus quels sont les différentes
options regarde les objectifs des textes
d'où cette préoccupation sur l'étude
d'options ces options n'étant pas
toujours encore une fois de manière de
nature purement normative
alors les évaluations explosent posent
une autre question elle devrait quant à
elle conduire à abandonner des normes ou
des
volets de politique publique
inefficaces trop complexe pour les
remplacer par des dispositifs plus
simples tirer les conséquences de ces
évaluations et que ces évaluations je
dirais ne soient pas de simples bilan
mais une analyse du pourquoi
c'est dans le dans la mise en oeuvre des
de ces dispositions et c'est ce que
j'évoquais avec toutefois la réserve sur
les clauses guillotines en guise
d'exemple un peu évidemment citer les
clauses de réexamen prévues pour les
lois de bioéthique successives la
dernière loi 2021 devra ainsi faire
l'objet d'un nouvel examen par le
Parlement dans un délai de 7 ans
en outre dans la suite alors de notre
étude de 2016 le Conseil d'État a cru
son contrôle des projets de textes et
nous essayons de mieux mesurer
l'inflation normative pour
prendre un petit peu la
portée complète alors s'agissant de nos
méthodes de travail
outre les recommandations que j'ai que
j'ai évoquées le Conseil d'État dans son
étude annuelle de 2016 pris 6
engagements avec le même souci d'en
créer un changement de culture normative
nous avons progressivement relevé notre
niveau d'exigence sur la qualité des
études d'impact et nous signalons donc
régulièrement comme j'ai dit leurs
insuffisances éventuelles c'est pas
toujours le cas mais dans certains cas
et depuis juin 2019 nous vérifions
l'insertion des indicateurs dans les
études d'impact des projets de loi
délibérant Conseil des ministres
la vie consultatif sur le projet de loi
relatif récent sur le projet loi relatif
à l'accélération des énergies
renouvelables adoptées par l'Assemblée
Générale en septembre dernier constitue
je crois un bon exemple de ces de ce
contrôle renforcé de la qualité du droit
puisqu'il pointe avec exigence les
insuffisances de l'étude d'impact du
projet de loi se montre soucieux d'un
certain nombre de questions de
lisibilité du droit et du niveau adéquat
législatif et réglementaire puisque nous
est arrivé de faire très très fermement
le partage pour faire respecter
l'article 34 et l'article 37 des
dispositions qui étaient soumises ils
formulent des propositions de
codification de certaines dispositions
plus ou moins pérennes dans les codes
correspondants mais aussi salut les
dispositions tendantes à la réduction du
nombre de procédures requises puisque ce
texte les prévoit donc c'est un exemple
un petit peu un petit peu topique de de
ce travail je tiens toutefois à
souligner une limite importante à ce
rôle du Conseil d'État
limite qui
environ
nous espérons en tout cas qu'elle ne se
renforcera pas ces dernières années on a
fait un bilan selon lequel à peu près
50% seulement des dispositions
législatives votées par le Parlement ont
été préalablement examinés par le
Conseil d'État par le l'évolution de du
débat
et donc évidemment en termes de pour
notre fils de d'appréciation de de la
cohérence et de la simplification des
textes c'est évidemment plus plus
délicat puisqu'une part évidemment ne
nous est pas soumis et les ordonnances
ont à l'opposé mais ça dans le champ des
déshabilitations qui sont proposées et
je ne me prononce que du point de vue du
Conseil d'État d'autres sujets
évidemment de beaucoup plus importants
qui l'emportent mais évidemment on
l'avantage de ne pas comporter de
dispositions qui n'ont pas fait l'objet
d'une analyse juridique et d'une
évaluation de leur impact par le par le
Conseil d'État
s'agissant en fin de la mesure de
l'inflation normative pour la mise en
oeuvre des propositions de 2016 le
vice-président Jean-Marc Sauvé a initié
une étude réalisée en 2018 en lien avec
le secrétariat général du gouvernement
et intitulé mesurer l'inflation
normative
ayant vocation à créer un référentiel
objectif de celle-ci cette étude a
abouti à la publication sur le site
Légifrance dans la rubrique qualité
simplification du droit d'une synthèse
inédite des statistiques de la norme qui
sont une sorte de tableau de bord de
l'inflation normative alors ce tableau
de bord permet il nous est très utile de
suivre le nombre de textes promulgués
par catégorie depuis 2002 l'allongement
des textes en cours de débat
parlementaires le volume absolu des
textes etc toute une série d'indicateurs
qui sont qui sont précieux pour
apprécier le flux et le stock des normes
en vigueur et ces indicateurs sont
également relatifs au taux d'application
des lois avec la préoccupation
évidemment que l'intention de
législateur soit bien respectée dans la
mise en oeuvre par le pouvoir
réglementaire relative au nombre des
articles au nombre de mots des textes et
à la stabilité dans le temps parce que
je crois qu'il y a un élément très
important
l'appréciation des normes qui font
l'objet de modification très très
fréquentes alors que d'autres contraires
montrent que la stabilité légitime et
réglementaire est possible ces
indicateurs pourraient à l'avenir en
tout cas c'est une réflexion que nous
avons inclure la production des
ministères non publiées au Journal
officiel et je reviens sur l'évocation
du du droit mood de la softlow qui prend
des recommandations des bonnes pratiques
des référentiels de tout ce qui envahit
progressivement un certain nombre de
secteurs avec de bonnes raisons mais
également qui constituent pour les
acteurs de ces secteurs évidemment
des éléments et des de cette inflation
normative même si ce n'est pas une norme
au sens classique du terme c'est plutôt
des quasi normes si vous me permettez
l'expression et notamment le droit
souple des autorités indépendantes ou
d'un certain nombre de de
d'établissements et très important et
prendre en compte l'origine de la norme
pour apprécier les éventuels sur
disposition de directive ou le coût
normatif réel d'une loi au regard de ce
texte d'application nous paraît une une
priorité en tout cas un élément
important de l'action publique et c'est
l'ensemble de ces indicateurs pourrait
offrir des perspectives intéressantes
d'amélioration donc de cette de cette
inflation je voudrais me simplement
terminer je vous m'y avais invité je
j'en suis heureux pour pour indiquer que
le Conseil d'État dans ces réflexions à
l'occasion de la rentrée qu'il a initié
en septembre sur ce sur ces activités
avec les représentants des pouvoirs
publics nous avons l'honneur
d'accueillir le président de du Sénat
nous avons annoncé que l'étude annuelle
du Conseil d'État qui est celle qui est
décidé de son propre chef qui
occupe l'institution notamment sous la
ou l'aide de la section du rapport et
des études et de sa présidente
l'étude annuelle serait consacrée cette
année et ce dont les résultats seront
présentés en septembre lors de la
deuxième rentrée du conseil au dernier
kilomètre
c'est à dire avec la volonté de prendre
un certain nombre d'exemples de
d'actions publiques de politiques
publiques en essayant de d'action
publique très concrètes en essayant de
regarder des exemples qui ont bien
fonctionné des exemples dans lequel les
politiques publiques n'ont pas trouvé
leur destinataire ou ne sont pas allés
jusqu'aux intéressés qu'elle devait
concerner ou ELLE qui elle devait rendre
service ou en tout cas répondre à leur
préoccupation et de faire cette analyse
de façon très large en lien avec
l'ensemble des membres de la juridiction
administrative pour remonter les
éléments qui apparaissent à travers
notamment les les problématiques
contentieuses à travers l'expérience des
membres de la juridiction donc c'est une
étude très très large dans laquelle
beaucoup de contributions sociétés qui
conduiront à rencontrer et qui ont déjà
commencé des rencontres beaucoup de
personnalités d'institutions de de
d'associations de personnes concernées
en essayant de de comprendre et de
d'analyser ce qui fait que l'application
concrète de la volonté du législateur ou
de la politique publique qui a été
initié a échoué ou au contraire à
parfaitement réussi plus ou moins réussi
etc alors cette étude est pour nous
extrêmement importante elle nous
positionne sur le dernier segment
d'application de la norme alors que nous
sommes plus habitués en tout cas dans un
certain nombre de de travaux évidemment
à être sur l'amende de la production de
la norme parce que c'est notre mission
constitutionnelle mais voilà je crois
que ce travail sera utilisé j'espère que
nous aurons l'occasion de et l'odeur de
pouvoir vous rencontrer pour échanger
dans le pendant le cours de ces travaux
et en tout cas que les les conclusions
que nous pourrons en tirer et que nous
présenterons en septembre prochain
pourront également être utile et
constituer une contribution
complémentaire aux travaux que vous
menezquel nous avons l'honneur de
participer aujourd'hui
le président et nous aimons beaucoup le
dernier kilomètre
ici même si parfois nous pouvons dans la
production
d'amendement oublié merci vraiment de
cette présentation
et revenir et ensuite faisons les choses
simplement où nous intervenons au
travers des questions
de notre expert
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Secrétaire général
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président
simplement déjà madame le présidente
vous a déjà posé beaucoup de questions
dans son
polyminaire moi je voudrais
simplement vous rappeler que c'est vrai
que nous allons avec
Madame Françoise Gatten notre présidente
fait des propositions sur ce sujet
en assistant sur la fabrique de la norme
mais ça a été dit et on pense que
finalement il faut qu'on ait une
approche préventive
ambitieuse pour que qu'on soit vraiment
efficace pour lutter sur le poids des
normes parce qu'on a à la fois le stock
de normes mais aussi le flux
comme en France nous votons beaucoup de
textes par rapport à nos partenaires
européens à peu près trois fois plus
donc on risque d'avoir trois fois plus
toujours de normes
et moi je voulais savoir par exemple
vous poser un certain nombre de
questions
par rapport au principe de précaution
qui a été inscrit dans la Constitution
d'après vous est-ce que c'est pas un
facteur qui a
augmenté le nombre de normes depuis son
inscription
dans la Constitution
est-ce que on n'est pas trop précis
aussi dans les textes que nous
faisons que nous votons Sénat à
l'Assemblée on va souvent on a une
quantité d'amendements qui nous emmène
vers une telle précision que
on augmente forcément les normes
j'avais fait une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle
à l'époque c'était avec mon ancien
président Jean-Marie Bockel qui a été
voté trois petits points l'unanimité au
Sénat il y a pas eu de suite mais avec
avec trois principes c'était de dire
voilà
une
énorme
apportée une norme supprimée
deuxième point celui qui décide la norme
paix donc ça ça permet déjà de
régler un certain nombre de problèmes et
puis la troisième le troisième sujet
c'était le problème de la
surtransposition européenne c'est-à-dire
que interdiction de surtransposer les
textes européens déjà ça
alors est-ce qu'il faut aller sur
opposition de loi constitutionnelle pour
essayer de
diminuer le nombre de normes est-ce que
c'est ça peut être une possibilité
j'avais aussi donc mais ça a été posé
par notre président quel était le regard
du Conseil d'État sur les études
d'impact est-ce que ça vous est arrivé
de rendre un avis négatif sur des
projets de loi
au motif qu'il présente un caractère
manifestement
lacunaire ou à Dijon ça c'était mais
aussi mais mes questions
et puis je souhaiterais également vous
interroger sur le CNN
puisque j'ai déposé en juin dernier une
résolution pour renforcer le rôle du CNN
et pour en faire un organe charnière
inspiré du
NKR allemand
et je propose en particulier de
rapprocher le CNE de l'Insee
sur le modèle allemand parce que si le
cnen se voit reconnaître un rôle de
certification des études d'impact il
faudrait un minima lui permettre de
recourir à des organes dotés de
compétences en économie ou en
statistiques et je voudrais rappeler à
cet égard que le
CNN ne dispose que peu de moyens
je vois que c'est à peu près à peine 6
équivalents de temps plein et uniquement
des profils juridiques
donc si la bonne moyen il pourra pas non
plus avancer
d'autre part je propose que le CNN soit
rattaché au service du Premier ministre
ce qui marquerait à la fois son
importance et la transversalité de son
action par nature interministérielle
et enfin comme tous les organes
consultatifs le cnen est une instance
indépendante qui ne reçoit la struction
d'aucune autorité
et toutefois
est-ce qu'il serait pas opportun ne
serait-ce que sur d'un point de vue
symbolique
de consacrer cette indépendance dans la
loi sans pour autant évidemment
transformer le conseil en autorité
administrative indépendante parce qu'on
sait bien que notre assemblée notamment
souhaite canaliser un peu la
prolifération de toutes ces instances
mais je pense que ça serait peut-être
aussi de marquer la notion de cette
instance de du CNN pour l'établir dans
le
au niveau de de son travail donc je
voulais savoir aussi quels étaient vos
relations avec le CNN et qu'est-ce que
vous pensez de toutes ces propositions
et de des éléments que j'ai pu vous
apporter
notamment aussi sur le principe de
précaution parce que je pense que ça a
été la base la base de beaucoup de
normes supplémentaires
je me suis présent je vais apporter
quelques éléments et puis si vous le
permettez les autres membres de la
délégation du Conseil d'État pourront
apporter
leur point de vue et les compléments
nécessaires sur le
l'enjeu général des textes vous avez
évoqué
début de votre intervention le la
précision de des textes effectivement
c'est un souci
très réel que l'on rencontre lors de
l'examen de chaque texte avec une sorte
de Dilemme
est-ce que le texte est très précis pour
tout prévoir ou est-ce que si les moins
précis il y aura une part plus
d'appréciation de l'administration du
service qui va mettre en oeuvre le texte
et cet équilibre entre faire confiance
au service et administration qui mettra
en oeuvre ou tout prévoir dans le cactus
soit au niveau législatif au niveau
réglementaire je crois que la tentation
ou la préoccupation est la même est un
vrai souci et on voit bien que au nom du
principe d'égalité on peut développer
des
des réglementations il nous est arrivé
d'ailleurs je dois le dire de d'y
contribuer en disant mais ce cas de
n'est pas prévu il est important est-ce
qu'il faut pas le prévoir et donc ça
peut contribuer à ce que les textes
soient plus précis comme vous le disiez
soit donc
apparemment plus simple plus clair plus
long également
mais qui peut être un facteur de convexé
parce que si on a quelques cas qui sont
évoqués dans le texte s'il y a des
interstices qui se présentent comme dans
la vie réelle on sait que le texte
permet de d'y régler au service public
de répondre si en revanche il y a une
très grande quantité de cas qui sont
prévues on se dit c'est le cas qui n'est
pas prévu c'est donc il est exclu
et on se peut se retrouver dans des
situations ou dans le dernier kilomètre
que nous évoquions ça peut aboutir à un
non accès au droit une difficulté donc
ça je crois que l'équilibre entre
la précision du texte et le
l'acceptation de laisser aux
administrations au service public
qu'elle soit territoriales ou d'état je
crois que ça ne change pas grand chose
une capacité de d'appréciation est une
question un sujet de réflexion que nous
avons je crois la réponse sans qu'elle
soit définitive c'est évidemment de
proportionner cette précision à
l'importance des matières traitées et
aux enjeux qui sont derrière mais je
crois que c'était un point important
je vous en prie continuerai sur les
autres
c'est un phénomène général quand même
qu'il y a aussi parfois une attente de
nos concitoyens c'est à dire de des
destinataires de la norme qui si elle
n'est pas suffisamment précise vous se
poser des questions donc je trouve que
cela accro au corps ou encore plus aiguë
le que vient de vous présenter le
vice-président parce que les
destinataires de la norme ce sont nos
concitoyens nos concitoyens ce sont les
collectivités territoriales sont tous
les acteurs finalement de la vie
publique
sur la question
qui ouvrait votre propos qui est une
question évidemment fondamentale je sais
pas si c'est le principe de précaution
en tant que tel au sens
environnemental du terme conçus analysé
ou que l'on retrouve en matière de santé
publique ou si c'est simplement le la
crainte et la révérence par rapport à la
norme d'une manière générale
et que qui effectivement peut être
renforcés au cours des derniers je sais
pas s'il secrétaire général qui qui
particulièrement
travaillé sur ces questions pour le
préciser mais je crois quand même quand
il y a une attention à la norme qui
s'est qui s'est renforcé et
cette norme très précise très
méticuleuse très qui qui se développe un
site à ce que ce le l'application de la
norme soit redoutée par les décideurs
par un certain nombre de
d'administration ou d'administrer
d'ailleurs parce que la question se pose
également pour les administrés qui sont
confrontés qui sont soumis à la norme et
qui peuvent être
inquiets de des conditions de son
application
effectivement ça rejoint ce que
soulignait la présidente de bois d'oeuf
beaucoup beaucoup d'acteurs sociaux qui
sont dans une logique de précaution qui
les conduit à être demandeur de normes
surtout tous ceux d'entre nous qui ont
été dans leur vie administrative
confrontés enfin ou chargé de politique
de simplification sur son heurter au
milieu intéressé qui était plutôt
demandeur de conserver des normes
notamment pour prévenir le risque
juridique et à l'intérieur du risque
juridique avec en particulier le risque
pénal on l'a vu à travers la gestion de
la crise sanitaire ou beaucoup des
acteurs étaient en attente de normes
pour préciser qu'elles étaient les
obligations des uns et les autres donc
c'est c'est un défi pour pour beaucoup
je voudrais revenir sur le troisième
point que vous avez évoqué sur les
organismes consultatifs sur le cnen et
la présence de MODEF
interviendra très très précisément pour
le Conseil d'État les organismes
consultatifs le disposer des avis des
organismes consultatifs au-delà de des
avis du CNN qui sont évidemment majeurs
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
fondamental parce que dans l'analyse
d'impact du choix des options que
j'évoquais sur lequel j'ai un petit peu
insisté évidemment les acteurs concernés
quand il y a des consultations
obligatoires en général sont des acteurs
qui sont directement concernés par le
projet leur analyse leur leur
ressenti et leur comment dire la façon
dont ils interprètent la norme qui leur
est soumise le projet qu'il aurait
soumis c'est absolument fondamental pour
nos travaux et nous nous avons souvent
regretté et dans le ça s'est traduit
dans certains cas par des mentions dans
la vie publique par exemple de disposer
que de quelques jours j'allais dire de
quelques pour examiner des avis
extrêmement importants et dans la je ne
peux je peux je ne peux pas ne pas citer
également le fait que par exemple pour
les projets de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale depuis les derniers
textes les avis ne nous sont plus soumis
puisqu'ils sont adressés directement
donc on peut pas en tirer la
quintessence alors qu'ils sont
évidemment très importants sur les
politiques de sécurité sociale comme si
donc ça les les organes consultatifs
dès lors que leur avis est obligatoire
et il nous arrive également d'avoir le
bénéfice d'avis qui n'était pas
obligatoire mais que le gouvernement a
spontanément
recueilli ce sont des éléments
fondamentaux de notre de notre propre
analyse d'impact et donc alors
évidemment ceux du CEN sont
particulièrement particulièrement
précieux je sais pas si tu souhaites
parler du CNN maintenant
oui tout à fait tout d'abord pour
insister vous le savez bien sûr
l'importance de vice-président il a
fallu Sion l'importance que nous
accordons aux avis du CNN et nous nous
efforçons toujours de l'avoir avant
d'examiner le texte avec les difficultés
que le temps vient de signaler la chose
aussi que nous constatons et
j'allais dire je rejoins monsieur
monsieur le Président l'analyse que vous
faisiez mais je pense qu'il est
compliqué pour nous de dire qu'il faut
augmenter des moyens financiers mais
c'est que ce que nous constatons c'est
que les avis du cnen aussi précieux
soit-il et parce qu'ils sont précieux
mais ne sont pas toujours aussi
peut-être
longuement motivé que sans doute le sén
le souhaiterait et que cela nous serait
utile pourquoi parce que le CNE
effectivement dans la composition dans
laquelle il est dans les moyens surtout
dont ils dispose vous les rappeliez tout
à l'heure
et doté de compétences très larges
puisque finalement quasiment tous les
textes quand un impact financier sur la
collectivité territoriale à cet
établissement public doivent leur être
doivent lui être soumis texte législatif
et réglementaire je le rappelle et donc
comment faire face à cela donc nous nous
sommes tout à fait
attachés à l'importance du travail du
Sénégal c'est un premier point deuxième
point nous y accordons beaucoup
effectivement d'intérêt et troisième
point une chose peut être une une piste
que j'avance très très prudemment que
nous avions évoqué dans notre étude de
2020 sur l'évaluation nous avions dit
dans notre propositions
qui étaient à proposition 10
d'approfondir peut-être de façon
sélective les études d'impact en
fonction des enjeux des textes
et ce serait peut-être une piste
qui évidemment est complémentaire de
celle que vous évoquez monsieur le
Président mais qui pourrait conduire je
crois que le cnoël le fait d'ailleurs
déjà parfois peut se dire que on va
mettre pardonnez-moi l'expression peu
familière le paquet sur un projet texte
tout à fait essentiel et le cnen et le
et tout à fait à même et peut-être le
mieux à même de définir justement cette
priorisation pour aller peut-être un peu
plus rapidement sur sur un autre projet
donc ça c'est est-ce que je voulais
indiquer alors ensuite sur le au-delà de
ce travail si j'ose dire que nous avons
avec lui ou de l'intérêt que nous
apportons à ce qu'il fait en cas de
notre fonction consultative et bien
effectivement pour pour la première fois
madame la Présidente vous vous y faisait
allusion c'était la première fois alors
que nous partageons beaucoup de
préoccupations depuis longtemps nous
avons organisé ce colloque donc le 14
octobre dernier
auquel participait également le
président Gérard puisqu'il a les
premières tables rondes parce que nous
pensions très important et intéressants
de se poser la question justement de la
simplification du point de vue des
collectivités territoriales et ça c'est
une donc ça a été une première
il y aura peut-être des suites nous
avons laissé l'avenir ouvert et surtout
je veux dire c'est dans tout à fait en
cohérence encore une fois avec ce que
nous avons dit notre dans notre étude
sur l'évaluation des politiques
publiques parce que nous avons insisté
vraiment sur la nécessaire coopération
entre l'État et les collectivités
territoriales pour l'évaluation des
politiques territoriales partagées et
nous avons même évoqué à ce sujet la
possibilité d'ouvrir l'accès l'accès à
des données pertinentes et importantes
donc aux collectivités territoriales et
d'augmenter les compétences d'appui à
l'Observatoire des finances et de la
gestion publique qui a déjà qui
s'efforce de jouer ce rôle et donc là on
a un autre élément qui pourrait
peut-être aussi nous permettre
d'améliorer cet évaluation
en prenant en compte le point de vue des
collectivités territoriales chose
qu'exprime le CNN et qui nous paraît et
j'y reviens tout à fait essentiel je ne
sais pas si j'ai répondu à à vos
questions monsieur le Président le
président Gérard va compléter c'est
juste un point de supplémentaire et
pratique lorsqu'il est inscrit alors du
jour d'une section administrative
l'examen d'un projet de décret et que
nous n'avons pas la vie du CNN
maintenant très souvent nous reportons
l'examen c'est-à-dire nous refusons
d'examen et donc ça veut dire qu'on
pourrait dire donnez-nous au dernierment
on refuse on reporte deuxièmement quand
on avait vu du cnen on pose souvent des
questions représentants du gouvernement
sur la façon dont ils en ont tenu compte
en disant mais pourquoi vous n'avez pas
repris ça et il nous arrive de reprendre
en compte des observations du CNF dans
les projets de décret nous transmettons
ensuite au gouvernement
ne sur le le fils qui est le nôtre dans
l'examen des textes parce que c'est
aussi une réflexion que
que nous menons je crois que notre notre
responsabilité c'est de mettre l'auteur
du texte en général c'est le
gouvernement puisque ce sont des projets
de décret de d'ordonnance ou de loi
[Musique]
en état d'apprécier les conséquences du
texte tel que nous les pouvons les
analyser avec l'expertise des membres du
conseil et dans le cadre de l'échange
avec les commissaires du Gouvernement et
comme l'a dit le président Gérard je
crois que le nous rendons notre avis
avec la même indépendance que nous
sommes au contentieux je crois que ces
fonctions consultatives ont des
conseillé deux mais afin de lui apporter
ce qui je crois et lui est le plus
précieux c'est à dire un avis totalement
indépendant
qui peut suivre ou ne pas suivre
évidemment ça c'est la responsabilité
politique et ça va de soi
et dans ce cadre je crois que lorsque
nous nous sur les études d'impact parce
que j'y reviens elles sont quand même
essentielles et je crois qu'elles sont
un outil d'avenir si
comment dire notre vision notre
conception et peut-être notre approche
continue à évoluer parce que je crois
qu'il se renforce c'est ces études
d'impact c'est l'occasion d'avoir toutes
les options qui sont possibles qui sont
des choix politiques donc ça nous
appartient pas de nous prononcer mais en
revanche de les comparer et de voir en
termes d'efficacité ce qui peut être le
plus efficace ça je crois que c'est
absolument dans notre dans notre dans
notre fils et on le fait je crois de
façon de plus en plus alors la question
se pose pour les projets de loi on a cet
instrument qui évidemment très précieux
en revanche évidemment pour les projets
de décret alors
je sais pas s'il faut systématiser c'est
une réflexion qu'on peut avoir mais en
tout cas pour les projets de décret les
plus importants en fait qui sont
porteurs d'une politique publique il y a
des projets décrets qui sont plus à la
marge etc mais pour ceux qui sont
porteurs d'une politique publique qui
sont la mise en œuvre la première mise
en œuvre d'une disposition législative
c'est vrai que nous aurions des éléments
d'impact qui vont au-delà de ce que l'on
peut obtenir dans l'échange avec les
commissaires du gouvernement il est
certain je suis en tout cas pour ma part
convaincu qu'on améliorait le travail
qu'on peut qu'on peut faire dans la
préparation des textes et ça c'est une
réflexion alors dans certains cas on a
on a parlé changé avec les commissaires
de gouvernement beaucoup d'indications
qui permettent d'enrichir le change et
qui peuvent mettre d'ailleurs de de
faire des propositions de textes à la
sortie de la section en général les
projets de décrenne vont pas en
assemblée générale ils sont rendus par
la section qui sont éventuellement
profondément modifiées par rapport au
texte qui a été soumis et je dois le
dire profondément modifié le plus
souvent avec l'accord des commissaires
du gouvernement il y a un travail
le co-construction qui se fait et qui
conduit le texte mais les éléments de
d'appréciation des différentes options
pourrait être renforcés
est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
rendre un avis négatif après une étude
d'impact sur des projets de loi
sur les projets de loi nous avons eu des
avis qui étaient très enfin comment dire
qui ne rejetait pas qui n'écartait pas
le projet mais qui mettait des
conditions très strictes de notre point
de vue de complément de l'étude impact
où nous précisions les éléments y
compris très concrets qui devaient être
ajoutés un étude d'impact avant le dépôt
au Parlement c'est notre façon de de
d'inviter le gouvernement à respecter
l'objet de l'obligation organique oui
c'est vraiment simplement pour eux si je
veux dire renchérir sur ce qu'a dit sur
le vice-président très honnêtement moi
sur les cinq dernières années moi je
siège en assemblée générale depuis 5 ans
maintenant nous avons renforcé notre
niveau d'exigence et si nous n'avons pas
jamais dit effectivement nous
pour vous éclairer et ça je crois que
c'est vraiment quelque chose enfin les
exemples les exemples abondent et mais
il est clair que la chose aussi sur
laquelle nous insistons beaucoup et ça
on ne le voit pas tellement c'est y
a-t-il eu cette étude d'option c'est ton
poser la question de savoir si on
pouvait faire son texte
vous pouvez faire autrement ça c'est une
chose je crois fondamentale et c'est une
question de culture je crois que vous
vous en avez parlé l'un et l'autre me
semble-t-il dans des écrits il faut
quand même que la culture
de la simplification de la sobriété
normative ou de la lutte contre
l'inflation nous irritent tous et je
crois que c'est à dire tous les auteurs
y compris pardonnez-moi j'en profite les
auteurs au niveau européen parce que
beaucoup de notre droit vient du niveau
européen soit par les transpositions
vous évoquez vous évoquiez tout à
l'heure cela monsieur le Président et
gentil un mot je crois que là il y a eu
tout un travail qui a été fait sur les
surtranspositions qui me semblent là
tout à fait efficace et puis vous allez
voir qu'en même temps on a le sentiment
que dans un certain nombre de domaines
de toute façon maintenant le droit
européen possède plus par règlement
que par directive et je pense je pense
notamment au domaine des réseaux sociaux
vous savez avec les deux règlements qui
viennent d'être adoptés qui vont être
mises en vigueur le DML DSL DJ all
market en matière de concurrence et le
DJ service Act qui lui concerne le
contenu et puis là ce sont des
règlements donc ils vont s'imposer et un
travail a été mené au niveau européen
pardonnez-moi ils sont aussi en anglais
better régulation mon meilleur
réglementation une meilleure législation
bon c'est effectivement c'est une
culture qui doit développer à tous les
niveaux des producteurs de normes et ils
sont nombreux et très divers de bas en
haut ou de haut en bas si j'ose dire
si vous permettez de rajouter un mot
dans les éléments de simplification moi
je crois également le respect rigoureux
du partage entre l'article 34 et
l'article 37 et le fait que des
dispositions réglementaires ne soient
pas intégrées dans la norme du châti ça
permet également lorsque de les modifier
plus facilement s'il y a une difficulté
donc d'adapter la législation de la
rendre plus
pas plus souple au sens juridique du
terme mais plus évolutive et je crois
que c'est c'est vraiment une bonne chose
et enfin dans la réflexion sur la
simplification alors moi je parle plutôt
avec mon ancienne casquette de président
de la section sociale qui est qui est
qui a été confronté pendant de
nombreuses années et notamment pendant
la période de la crise sanitaire où il y
a beaucoup de textes qui qui venaient
d'ailleurs plutôt des textes sur
l'État-providence que sur la santé
publique pour des raisons qui qui sont
compréhensibles et moi je crois que la
simplification c'est pas simplement la
simplification de la norme dont on parle
parce qu'on peut avoir une norme
extrêmement plutôt bien faite j'irai
simplifié qui vient télescoper deux ou
trois autres champs législatif et
réglementaires qui vient se superposer à
d'autres champs et qui rend pour
l'usager ou pour l'administration qu'il
applique la régle la législation
extrêmement difficile alors pourtant que
cette législation au départ si on la
regarde de façon autonome
elle apparaît bien faite elle est assez
compréhensible mais quand on a superpose
avec les autres on se rend compte que
c'est difficile et là je crois que c'est
aussi dans le fils du Conseil d'État
avec le fait que nous voyons législation
à 360 degrés parce que entre les
différentes sections et je crois que cet
élément de de complexité doit également
être pris en compte parce que il produit
des effets qui peuvent être parfois un
petit peu un petit peu surprenant alors
je prendrai pas l'exemple que de
l'urbanisme et de l'environnement où on
a des législations qui viennent se
surposer mais dans le dans le secteur
social on a également des des
législations qui viennent se télescoper
se superposer et qui produisent de la
complexité alors que chacune d'elles
peut être relativement bien rédigée
c'est justement on rejoint la question
de la culture parce que la culture quand
même de la production de normes elle est
très en silo on a rarement une vision
globale on ne s'intéresse pas toujours à
ce qui se passe ailleurs et justement
tous les effets de bord si je veux dire
qui peuvent qui peuvent en résultat en
résulter ainsi que vient de l'analyser
monsieur Elvis président
culture de la pertinence de la norme et
de la loi dans un pays aussi cartésien
que le nôtre on s'est homme de ce on va
dire
de ce changement profond
qui fait que nous avons de plus en plus
de lois qui naissent de l'émotion d'une
situation particulière comme s'il
fallait pour assurer
ou anesthésie et peut-être l'opinion
publique selon les pratiques il faut
produire un texte donc à la fois on se
dit que nos concitoyens ont l'impression
que la loi est miraculeuse c'est-à-dire
la loi guéri et on se rend compte aussi
que ça ne fonctionne pas donc ça c'est
un sujet donc est-ce qu'à un moment on
peut
ramener de la raison et de la rigueur
grâce effectivement ce que vous évoquez
dont on parle assez peu qui est l'étude
d'option
c'est à dire en examine l'objet qui nous
préoccupe est-il nécessaire de procéder
à une nouvelle réglementation ou avant
nous d'autres options mais on a vous
voyez cette idée de calmer l'opinion
publique ça c'est quand même un sujet
chez nous une vraie dérive deuxièmement
vous avez souligné quelque chose que
nous évoquons souvent l'approche
systémique c'est-à-dire on voit en
matière d'urbanisme ou amer peut être
confronté à deux normes l'une en matière
de sécurité incendie l'une en matière
d'accessibilité qui vont faire qu'à un
moment elle se télescope et que donc
vous ne pouvez rien faire
et qu'on peut avoir des administrations
qui vous lisent exclusivement la
question du handicap n'est pas mon sujet
moi je suis sur la sécurité incendie
donc vous comprendrez que
voilà je maintiens parce que
il y a une responsabilité qui s'enchaîne
donc ça ça me paraît extrêmement
important ensuite il y a cette chaîne de
la production je vais prendre l'exemple
de la loi climat et résilience
qui
intégrit une disposition qui s'appelle
le zéro artificialisation nette donc la
chose merveilleuse qui fait que dans
notre pays on a inventé un remède
miraculeux qui fit que on aurait guéri
de tout le monde
on voit que c'est un exemple qui
illustre très bien ce que vous dites il
y a pas eu d'approche systémique parce
qu'en même temps on doit
réindustrialiser
donc consommer voilà en même temps si je
puis dire on a 5 millions 700000
logements qui sont des passes par
thermique qui demain matin seront
interdits de location donc on a 5
millions 700 logements qu'on ne va pas
pouvoir utiliser on nous dit zéro
artificialisation
donc il y a pas du tout eu d'approche
systémique on a rien évalué aujourd'hui
nous sommes en train de retravailler
pour corriger la loi et
le décret d'application qui est sorti
il est on va dire en contradiction avec
l'esprit du législateur parce qu'il fait
qu'on ne peut plus rien faire là encore
et donc le décret d'application a été
attaqué si je puis dire par
l'Association des maires de France dont
nous recevons le président tout à
l'heure et le Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes c'est prononcé à
aimer un avis défavorable sur ce décret
d'application c'est quand même un signe
mais le décret d'application a poursuivi
sa route et la machine administrative à
poursuivi sa route parce que depuis le
mois d'août nous avons au Conseil
national évaluation d'évaluation des
normes deux dispositifs nous avons eu
deux décrets d'application à examiner
en application de texte qui n'était pas
celui de climat et résidence mais
naturellement le fonctionnaire dans une
disposition thématique il a pris en
compte toutes les lois y compris
climates donc nous avons eu à examiner
au Conseil national d'évaluation des
normes une disposition qui prenait en
compte le décret d'application
du Zéro artificialisé si on est sur
lequel nous avions émis un avis négatif
qui faisait l'objet d'un recours et sur
lequel nous avions interrogé le ministre
monsieur Béchu et nous avions convenu
Sénat et ministre que nous allions
procéder à des corrections
donc vous voyez que même quand il y a
toute une alerte qui est fait la machine
continue à avancer et et insidieusement
vient peu polluer des choses parce que
les administrations l'obligation de
produire des décrets d'applications vous
voyez donc on est totalement
encombré si je puis dire d'une manière
parfois insidieuse par donc c'est
décrets d'application sur lesquels on
dit non non on va corriger ça donc
comment peut-on d'une manière
raisonnable à faire les choses alors
est-ce que vous pensez que la pratique
introduit aujourd'hui le gouvernement et
c'est très récent
d'une association des parlementaires à
l'écriture des décrets d'application
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne chose
comment peut-on et comment peut-on
améliorer les choses
bien évidemment du cas que vous avez
présenté je ne me prononcerai pas vous
le comprendrez puisque effectivement le
le Conseil d'État est saisi au
contentieux et donc c'est quelque chose
sur lequel nous ne pouvons pas
intervenir juste pour souligner on a eu
cette semaine les journées du
contentieux qui étaient consacré aux
droits de l'urbanisme
avec d'ailleurs une intervention de
notre ancien président de la section du
contentieux Daniel labetoul qui est un
grand spécialiste de ces matières et où
les questions paradoxales que vous avez
soulignées
télescopage ou de contradiction entre
des dispositions ont été analysées et
discutés pendant toute cette journée
donc c'était un point qui nous
préoccupait je voudrais vous donner un
peut-être un autre exemple de résolution
et puis je viendrai tout de suite à la
question de enfin non je peux d'ailleurs
répondre tout de suite à la question que
vous posez sur le l'association des
parlementaires à la mise en oeuvre de la
loi c'est-à-dire que ça c'est une
question d'ordre pleinement politique
qui sur lequel moi je ne peux pas
émettre un avis c'est c'est la façon
dont la collectivité veut s'organiser au
plus haut niveau entre le pouvoir
exécutif et le pouvoir législatif et ça
je veux dire voilà je ne peux que
souhaiter que les textes soient d'autant
plus
d'autant mieux construit mais je n'ai
évidemment pas de pas de d'opinion à
exprimer sur sur ce point sur la sur la
question de de la comparaison et de
l'appréciation des différentes
politiques et des différentes
législations moi j'ai un exemple en tête
qui est un travail que nous avons fait
au Conseil d'État à la demande du
gouvernement on avait d'ailleurs discuté
avec eux et qui personnellement me
paraît plutôt une voix intéressante nous
avions été saisis par le le gouvernement
de la question de
la prise en compte des ressources pour
l'attribution des différentes
prestations sociales
qui est un maquis pour ceux qui ont eu
l'occasion de le connaître ou
d'accompagner un demandeur de RSA ou
d'accompagner un demandeur d'aide au
logement qui est assez intéressant de de
voir la façon dont cette complexité
s'exprime alors là on n'est pas dans le
dernier kilomètre on est dans le dernier
centimètre de de l'action publique et
nous avons donc eu un groupe de travail
sous la présidence du président Joss qui
s'est réuni et qui a produit une étude
proposant que dans un premier temps mais
parce que le allait plus loin être
visible et en fait deux systèmes de
prise en compte rénovation le système
fiscal parce qu'il a des bases à une
logique différente et que une image
n'est pas que la fusion puisse se faire
même si dans dans l'absolu c'était
Mozart et surtout une base unique pour
les prestations sociales
qui est un chantier considérable qui
parce qu'il y a des perdants des
gagnants qu'il y a quelque chose qu'il
faut faire comme vous disiez les
conditions de mise en oeuvre ce serait
sur le flux et pas sur le stock si j'ose
dire de des prestations parce que s'il y
a des difficultés mais cette approche
transversale des différentes
législations de de protection sociale a
pu être faite dans un cadre voilà je
dirais en quelques mois c'est pas une
étude qui a été d'ailleurs menée pendant
très longtemps qui a pu aboutir assez
vite en six mois et qui permet de
justement d'éviter le télescopage de
législation en tout cas de rationniste
je crois que dans beaucoup de domaines
ce type d'approche transversale alors on
peut relever soit du Parlement mais qui
peut être dans notre fils si on nous
saisit de cette question ce sont des
choses qui peuvent éviter sur des
législations complexes les les effets de
bord qui parfois sont extrêmement
préjudiciables
peut-être simplement madame la
Présidente
dans votre présentation de la question
qui vient d'être posée vous indiquiez on
est submergé de décret d'application
mais en même temps
on surveille cela parce que si une loi
est votée et que son application
dépendante entre en vigueur de décret
qui est quand même ennuyeux que c'est
des cris n'interviennent pas ou alors
ici personne ne s'en préoccupe c'est
peut-être que la loi n'était pas utile
alors voilà donc il y a si vous voulez
là mais il y a effectivement ensuite
évidemment le souci que le décret
d'application et nous y veillons quand
nous les voyons le décret d'application
face qu'appliquer la loi justement qu'il
ne rajoute pas des conditions
supplémentaires ou qu'ils ne modifie
peut-être pas
de façon plus ou moins nette l'intention
du législateur
voilà je voulais vraiment voilà vous
vous à nouveau pour remercier souhaité
que ce dialogue que nous avons vraiment
plaisir à avoir avec vous puisses
effectivement
ce poursuivre et en tout cas vous dire
que le thème de l'étude que vous avez
retenu pour cette année
recueillera notre attention la plus
grande et la plus absolue parce que je
pense que en tout cas c'est le souhait
aussi du président l'archet que dans le
travail ou la réflexion qui l'a lancé
comme je le disais avec l'ensemble des
groupes politiques
avec ce souci d'efficacité de l'action
publique le chant de la simplification
au sens de l'efficience
sera au coeur de au cœur de nos
progressions parce que ce que nous
n'avons pas dit c'est que la norme elle
a un coût et que je pense que
aujourd'hui ou comme nous discutons un
budget nous sommes sur diminution des
ressources ou diminutions des dépenses
qu'un moment voilà l'exercice vient
difficile sauf à perdre le sens de
l'action publique moi je pense qu'il y a
de l'optimisation à faire sur de la
dépense intelligente et que parfois
alléger un peu la norme en gardant son
sens peut permettre d'être plus efficace
et de récupérer un peu de moyens et
enfin on le voit dans l'examen du du
projet de loi de finance enfin jamais on
ne parle de diminution de normes voilà
on est vraiment sur des approches
extrêmement comptables d'addition il
soustraction pour arriver
équilibre merci vraiment alors nous
allons poursuivre notre conversation sur
ce sujet avec le président de
l'association des maires qui a décidé
lui aussi de partir en campagne
contre la norme voilà contre la norme
comme nous voilà donc moi je me réjouis
que
chacun porte autant d'intérêt à tout ça
et je me renouvelle mes remerciements
il faudrait qu'ils avoue elle venaient
là
le monsieur le Président
de l'Association des maires de je sais
que vous avez une contrainte horaire
liée à votre sacerdoce associatif donc
voilà voilà
vraiment voilà un sénateur de la somme
donc on va être respectueux je vous prie
aussi d'excuser le fait que il y a des
disparitions
il y a des il y a des il y a des il y a
des atterrissages dans cette salle parce
qu'en fait il y a le PLF en même temps
donc c'est voilà le train de sénateur
monsieur
le Président en tout cas vraiment
monsieur le Président cher David merci
merci beaucoup de ce dialogue très
nourri que nous avons avec vous-même
avec tous les membres de votre conseil
d'administration et les collaborateurs
de la MF que je souhaite vraiment
remercier aussi et puis je voulais
saluer la qualité
du congrès des maires de la semaine
dernière qui a réuni une assistance
nombreuse où les travaux étaient comme
d'habitude de qualité et vous dire voilà
l'attention que le Sénat porte
aux collectivités en ayant au cœur de de
cette attention la commune qui pour nous
est vraiment le cœur du réacteur parce
qu'elle permet de répondre à cette
exigence de proximité qui s'exprime de
plus en plus et si nous ne comprenions
pas nos concitoyens expriment d'une
manière violente
on l'a vu récemment avec les crises
sociales alors nous partageons monsieur
le Président au-delà de l'attachement à
la commune
une obsession que je trouve salutaire
que nous avons
beaucoup manifesté depuis ce matin
puisque vous l'avez vu nous recevions
déminant membre du Conseil d'État pour
parler
de la norme de son efficience
parce que notre obsession aussi c'est
celle de l'efficacité de l'action
publique jusqu'au dernier kilomètre et
le Conseil d'État à cette année comme
thématique d'études le fameux dernier
kilomètre donc l'idée c'est comment on
bride l'inflation normative comment la
contrôler
et les uns et les autres nous prenons
notre part dans ce sujet comme vous le
savez le président
l'archet il a exprimé
au Congrès des associations membres de
territoires unis à lancer un groupe etc
en quelque sorte de faire des
propositions autour de l'efficacité de
l'action publique alors il y a des
centralisations déconcentrations mais
nous nous portons et Rémi pointron par
Laurent encore mieux que moi parce que
c'est lui qui est en charge ce sujet à
la délégation nous souhaitons vraiment
qu'il y ait
un volet sur la simplification sans que
nous ne soyons trop simplifi sur le
sujet on sait que on sait que c'est fort
compliqué parce que au-delà parfois
de normes qui viennent contrarier
l'efficacité de l'action publique de
normes qui se télescopent il y a
une autre préoccupation qui aujourd'hui
dans l'air du temps c'est celle du cou
puisque nous participions monsieur le
Président vous et moi au colloque au
Conseil d'État sur le sujet le 14
octobre et
on a entendu que le coût des normes
produite entre 2017 et 2021
coup annoncé par la DGCL c'est 2
milliards d'euros donc je pense qu'à un
moment où il y a la fois de l'exigence
d'efficacité mais qu'il y a une
préoccupation financière majeure je
pense que nous pourrions parfois être
plus opérant plus efficace moins
dispendieux en réajustant le niveau de
norme et il y a là je pense des pépites
de prospection
que moi je regrette de ne pas voir
actionner quand en ce moment nous sommes
le projet de loi de finances et la
question c'est toujours on diminue les
dépenses un peu et c'est très bien comme
des comptables et on oublie le sens des
choses et on diminue aussi les
ressources voilà monsieur le Président
j'ai essayé d'être assez
brève donc la question que je vous pose
monsieur le Président là même que vous
vous avez lancé cette réflexion alors
que faire
et vous avez une arme sur le précédent
avec les questions de mes collègues
dire simplement d'avoir à quel point je
suis la relation qui est celle qui est
une relation organique évidente entre le
Sénat et l'AMF une relation encore plus
organique en plus évidente entre votre
délégation aux collectivités
territoriales et l'Association des
maires de France mais au-delà de ça la
relation personnelle avec vous avec un
certain nombre de sénateurs ici qui font
qu'on avance concrètement au gré de
l'agenda
législatif imposer en grande partie par
l'exécutif comme le veut les règles de
la 5e République et au-delà de cet
agenda aussi sur une certaine vision
d'organisation des pouvoirs publics et
dans votre propos liminaire vous vous
placez je pense la barre où il le faut
c'est à dire qu'il est temps de faire
des renversements
d'approche complet parce qu'autrement on
ira dans le mur de la réponse à la
question que vous posez très claire
alors que faire la réponse qui a
toujours été apportée à cette question
qui est récurrente
depuis une trentaine d'années face à
l'excès de norme c'est faire des normes
pour supprimer des normes donc je vais
vous dire comment et pourquoi à mon sens
avec une liberté de ton qui j'espère ne
n'ira pas à l'encontre de ma
responsabilité de président de tous les
maires
je suis surveillé par par Charlotte qui
qui m'accompagne et qui est mon Jiminy
Cricket lorsque je rencontre des
parlementaires voilà c'est ma conscience
donc pour après cette s'était lancé
d'abord vous remercier aussi de votre
participation de votre présence au
Congrès ça paraît simple c'est pas
simple un tel congrès c'est le plus
grand rassemblement d'élus peut-être au
monde c'est pas en fatigue que de dire
parce qu'on a une structure communale
différente parce que c'est très bien
organisé par une association qui est une
petite structure la MF c'est un commando
de gens très motivés et on a eu une
fréquentation peut-être encore cette
année en inscrit à la fois sur la partie
salon et sur la partie congrès puisque
les deux constituent la même entité de
notre rassemblement Porte de Versailles
et avec 400 événements dont une
quarantaine sur le congrès lui-même de
de haut niveau qui nous ont permis de
d'informer de dénoncer de proposer et en
bonne interaction avec l'exécutif
puisque les ministres sont joués le jeu
sont venus la première ministre il y a
veillée et je trouve que tout cela était
assez réjouissant
la tonalité de la résolution et vraiment
je vous qui êtes ici à la Chambre haute
à la Grande Chambre des communes comme
je crois que c'est Gambetta qui disait
ça je vous invite à lire la résolution
le texte de la résolution qui a été voté
à l'unanimité des membres de l'AMF et la
MF représente tout le spectre politique
tout le spectre notamment les nombres en
cartés qui sont dominants mais également
donc les personnes plus engagées et avec
une représentation des proches de
l'exécutif enfin des de pouvoir en place
qui est importante au sein des instances
de la MFA donc c'est un texte important
parce qu'il est c'est pas un petit
dénominateur commun c'est un haut
multiplicateur commun
qui je crois est un peu différent des
résolutions des années précédentes y
compris sur le ton et qui fait valoir
des principes forts
pour les communes et les
intercommunalités puisque l'association
de la MF c'est l'association des maires
est président d'intercommunalité
sur donc je serais moi à votre
disposition sur sur la grosseur que nous
avons sur les questions que vous
souhaitez
l'actu budgétaire financière
sur le zan je pense que voilà qui qui
nous qui nous préoccupe et qui est qui
est la bombe à retardement dont la et
qui était à la fois de montbardent mais
une bombe à fragmentation fragmentation
territoriale à fragmentation politique à
fragmentation civique
fragmentation économique et qui comme
toujours avec l'enfer qui est pavé de
bonnes intentions par d'une nécessité
qui est celle de lutter contre
l'artificialisation mais qui se traduit
dans une approche une fois de plus
centralisatrice et pas forcément
centralise qu'au niveau de l'Etat et si
on a le temps d'en parler
on va changer de ton avec l'AMF sur
les formes de centralisation quelle
qu'elle soit ce culte des grands
ensembles n'est plus possible et il
n'est plus possible pour notamment par
rapport à la thématique que vous mettez
au coeur de notre échange aujourd'hui
qui est celle de la simplification
donc je vais vous parler un peu
spontanément et apprendre à vos
questions mais je disais tout à l'heure
de façon liminaire que les réponses qui
avaient été apportées jusqu'à maintenant
aux besoins de simplification était des
besoins de complications
pour une raison pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que on a une pratique en
France qui consiste à ajouter
et on en est tous responsable depuis des
décennies les maires les sénateurs les
députés les ministres les présidents on
a sur une par un biais évident on a
l'impression d'apporter quelque chose en
ajoutant une disposition
et donc ce qui peut être le cas mais qui
parfois nous éloigne de la performance
et et complique les choses deuxièmement
parce qu'il y a quand même un
conformisme dans la pensée lorsque l'on
arrive au prisme de la de l'exécution
des décisions politiques prises
je vais essayer de plus précis lorsque
François Hollande qui avait comme
souvent d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de
d'intelligence analyser vous voyez que
je suis mais je disais avant j'ai
toujours trouvé que c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent et qui avait une capacité
didactique très forte
je trouve qu'il était moins bon dans
l'exécution des choses et dans la
présidence je pense que voilà c'est
l'opposant cette politique là mais avait
analysé la problématique de la de la
complication qui qui revient
régulièrement
je fais une précision qui n'est pas une
divagation enfin j'espère qui n'est pas
une digression qui est une précision
celle que je distingue complication et
complexification et je crois qu'il faut
le faire tout par des mots
la complexité c'est souvent un progrès
la complication c'est quasiment tout le
temps une régression
pourquoi la complexification ou la
complexité est un progrès parce que la
complexité elle renvoie à une subtilité
humaine pour répondre à des situations
par exemple
quand on est complexifié
la construction des bâtiments pour que
les bâtiments par des normes soient
résistent mieux autrementaire aux
incendies ou soit plus accessibles au
mieux accessible aux personnes
handicapées c'est une complexification
qui est pertinente c'est un progrès
social un progrès un progrès tout court
en revanche la complication
c'est lorsqu'on est incapable d'aller
jusqu'au bout du geste et donc qu'on
ajoute des dispositions de précaution
qui elle alourdissent le quotidien et
c'est nuancerique très importante à mes
yeux parce que et on le voit très bien
organisation et je resterai dans ma
cohérence des grands ensembles ou pas
mais en management de privé en
entreprise dans l'entreprise le débat a
été tranché depuis longtemps
beaucoup de parce que les entreprises
ont exactement les mêmes problèmes
d'excès de normes d'excès de
complications que le public
c'est plus plus qu'un statut c'est une
question de taille et on le voit très
bien dans les grandes boîtes les grandes
boîtes lutte en permanence contre
l'effet de procédure de process cette un
petit livre qui est très qui est très
facile et qui est très pertinent de la
philosophe Julia de Funès
le nom me sort de la tête mais vous vous
galérez vous trouverez tout de suite sur
la dictature des process quoi en quelque
sorte c'est à dire quand et la
complication c'est quand la modalité
devient finalité et qu'on oublie même la
finalité
et puis c'est là que entre la machine à
broyer
et parfois on en est nous-mêmes des
acteurs de cette machine à Breuil je dis
nous-mêmes par j'espère ne pas en être
mais mais si forcément bon et donc
j'essaie de faire l'entonnoir dans mon
propos mais je pensais pas qu'on
partirait comme ça sur ce thème là mais
tant mieux parce que moi c'est un thème
qui est au cœur de mon engagement donc
c'est peut-être celui qui me motive le
plus
et la machine à broyer alors une des
dispositions qui était proposée par par
le ministrement dont était de dire
on répond à pleine courrier inutiles
l'absence de réponse vaut acceptation
vous souder on a tous des légiférer des
libérés
et puis arrive ensuite donc les
interministériels les trucs moi je suis
pas spécialiste vous connaissez mieux ça
que moi et le truc qui devait être
simple en fait devient le nombre de
dérogations
et comment ça se traduit dans une mairie
donc nous on mairie on dit tiens donc on
dit est-ce qu'on va éviter de faire des
courriers inutiles etc et ça se traduit
à la fin par vous devez recruter
quelqu'un qui doit analyser si on doit
répondre ou pas donc la décision vous
prenez dit bon on arrête ce délire on
répond à tout le monde c'est plus simple
ça sera beaucoup plus simple que que de
revenir là-dessus parce que on a
multiplié les dérogations dire à ton ami
là si on répond pas ça peut poser tel
type l'ambiguïté etc
les dans le privé il y a eu plusieurs
chercheurs notamment américains je sais
plus si c'est l'université Chicago enfin
une autre qui avait démontré que quand
on complexifié qu'en multiplié par deux
une complexification en multiplié par 10
il y avait un rapport de 1 à 5 la
complication et d'ailleurs lorsqu'on
démarre lancer une volonté de démarche
qualité qui a été un des grands trucs du
début des années 2000
on a les entités créent une direction de
la qualité
donc qui était consommatrice de moyens
et qui elle-même elle est perturbée
et produisait même de la norme de la
soft normale de la norme par
réglementaire donc pourquoi je vous dis
ça c'est que ce thème là sera un serpent
de mer si on en renverse pas
complètement la problématique et c'est
une problématique politique c'est-à-dire
et cette philosophique qui consiste à
dire que le risque
paye plus que la couverture absolue
qui consiste à dire que
l'induction l'ordre spontané pour citer
Raymond Boudon il vaut mieux avoir
Raymond raison avec Boudon que Thor avec
Bourdieu
pour partager pour paraphraser à notre
mot
l'ordre spontané ça fonctionne très bien
et que la puissance publique doit
intervenir à posteriori et pas a priori
voilà et ça c'est une question
philosophique majeure sauf une fois
qu'on se le dit ça paraisse évident mais
dans la réalité on passe notre temps à
recréer des contraintes a priori la
simplification c'est celle qui permettra
de revenir à l'essence même de l'État
c'est à dire des dispositions d'ordre
public
contrôler a posteriori et
sanctionner rapidement et fortement
donc lorsqu'elles ne sont pas respectées
enfin en tout cas sanctionner ceux qui
ne respecte pas
et c'est à dire substituer or on le voit
très bien et on en arrive au sujet des
collectivités moi je l'ai vu je suis élu
local depuis 2001 j'ai été directeur de
cabinet avant et puis j'ai vu une vie
privée publique jusqu'en 2016 maintenant
j'ai plus que des fonctions publiques
mais je vois très bien que on est passé
d'un régime de d'autorisation d'un
régime de liberté un régime
d'autorisation et donc que on perd de
l'efficacité on perd du temps on perd de
l'efficacité on perd de l'argent pour
reprendre ce que ce que vous disiez ma
présidente et on perd des nerfs et
surtout on perd du civisme parce qu'on
alimente l'impuissance publique et une
des principales causes de la crise
civique majeure que nous vivons
aujourd'hui qui sera traduit par les
taux d'abstention qui se traduit par les
extrémisme des positions
proportionnelles à la vacuité de la
pensée qui se traduit par le dénigrement
par
la dictature de l'instantané qui se
traduit par la violence y compris sur
les élus tous ces sujets qu'on est mort
de souvent ici dans cette belle maison
comme AMF une des causes majeures de la
crise civique alors il y a des
intellectuelles structurelles le doute
occidental le la postmodernité
l'absurdité de 14-18 la Shoah etc qui
font qu'on doute qui apporte un
relativisme qui apporte du nihilisme bon
on n'est pas là pour faire de la philo
mais en fait il faut toujours faire un
peu de philo mais mais très concrètement
et c'est très vraiment en ce moment
c'est l'impuissance publique quand vous
dites je condamne avec la plus grande
fermeté cette agression plus jamais nous
laisserons faire ça et puis que le
lendemain l'agresseur est libéré
on crée l'énervement des âmes et des
cœurs comme disait Tocqueville voilà
donc l'impuissance publique et la
complexation
normative crée de l'impuissance publique
et elle crée donc elle crée de c'est une
spirale de la défiance défiance de la
puissance publique qui dit les individus
doivent être contrôlés a priori normes
excès de réglementation encadrement
schéma directeur
opposable et tout des machins que l'on
ne cesse de créer pour des bonnes
raisons qui indépendamment se justifient
vous savez chaque séquence est justifie
puis à la fin le film il est très
pénible et
je m'y connais
c'est un film long et pénible Julien
spécialiste ma fonction et et
deuxièmement on crée de l'impuissance
publique et pour le coup on le voit très
bien chez les maires qui qui que vous
devez rencontrer puisque vous êtes
sénateur et les élus locaux
dans l'Allier je dirais récemment dans
l'Allier et la présidente des maires de
l'Allier qui est quand même très
dynamique très concrète qui qui a su
réunir au-delà des clivages partisans
dans un département qui était très
marqué
me disait que le nombre il me montrait
statistiques à l'appui que le nombre de
démissions d'élus municipaux maire
adjoint conseiller municipaux était un
en deux ans de 2020 à 2022 ils ont fait
deux fois plus que sur les 6 années
précédentes donc ça fait ça fait 6 fois
plus quoi si je tombe pas voilà donc et
je pense qu'une des causes majeure est
la difficulté à exécuter
des décisions de tous les tous les
projets de mandat ne sont pas
fantaisistes beaucoup de mères sont des
gens l'immense majorité c'est des ventes
très concrets très pragmatique il y a
parfois des gens qui promettent
n'importe quoi mais c'est assez rare au
plan municipal donc les projets de
mandat sur lesquels on est élu ils sont
plutôt raisonnables ils tiennent compte
des contraintes de la commande publique
de la difficulté décisionnelle or on se
rend compte que même en en tenant compte
même en mettant des filets de sécurité
financier juridique et temporelle on a
de plus en plus de mal à exécuter nos
projets de mandat donc ça alimente la
spirale infernale de la défiance les
citoyens mais j'ai lu il devait refaire
la place machin ou la fontaine trucmuche
ou créer une Maison des Jeunes et puis
c'est toujours pas sorti de terre le
maire travaille comme un dingue il est
de bonne foi son administration aussi
donc c'est une question et vous avez
raison de la mettre au coeur de vos
travaux fondamental LMF on a créé ce
comité législatif local aussi dans cette
optique en participant aux travaux du
cnen qui est vraiment particulièrement
bien présidé par Lambert qui est
formidable qui remarquable bon qui à la
fois dans sa vision didactique des
choses et son quotidien
et on a vu la dérive c'est les derniers
mois l'année dernière on a eu je crois
plus de 300 décrets sur l'école on a dû
se prononcer et je crois que les deux
tiers étaient en urgence mais Charlotte
le mieux que moi et et des décrets de
plus en plus longs
et on a vu sur justement le zan et la
loi climat est résilience le caractère
non seulement abscons des décrets dans
la vie sur la nomenclature par exemple
sur Lausanne bon et les mêmes contraires
à la loi sur l'avait évoqué d'ailleurs à
l'assemblée des mers des Alpes-Maritimes
sur la contradiction avec le caractère
normatif ou pas opposable ou pas dans
les stradettes de l'inscription non plus
dans les documents d'objectif dans les
objectifs qui étaient prévus par la loi
mais dans les règles du fascicule qui
deviennent opposables donc là dessus moi
je termine dans cette introduction très
générale de principe la seule solution
et c'est là que je disais la MF va en
tout cas je vais proposer qu'on change
de ton parce qu'à chaque fois on discute
on veut bien faire on veut pas bloquer
on a raison mais à un moment donné la
gangrène bureaucratique elle elle
continue de prospérer et les textes
qu'on a en train d'examiner y compris
sur les énergies renouvelables
voilà et le zan la loi climat est
résilience en fait va s'avérer comme une
loi et j'ose le dire ici et je pardon
pour ce on a tous essayé de bosser pour
que la CNP soit conclusive ça a été d'un
accouchement douloureux par sans ces
responsabilités mais en fait c'est une
mauvaise loi et cette loi va être encore
pire à appliquer localement que d'autres
grandes lois qui nous posent difficultés
qu'on ne cesse de détricoter pour les
rendre applicables comme la loi SRU ou
bon donc
là-dessus la seule façon maintenant
c'est de dire est-ce qu'on est capable
en France de c'est une question de
d'approche de sortir du cadre et de dire
stop
la suivi
la responsabilité et la seule matrice de
l'efficacité et pour qu'ils
responsabilité il faut deux choses il
faut que liberté et il faut qu'il y ait
contrôle et sanctions si on sort des
dispositions de Republique moi je
souhaite qui est plus de liberté et que
les et qui est du contrôle a posteriori
et que ceux qui sortent des clous soit
soit sanctionnés y compris au plan pénal
bon voilà la philosophie générale parce
que tout le reste tout le reste à chaque
fois on va ajouter ah oui ne regardez
dans tel cas si on met pas ça regardez
sur le zan
on est en train de tous se triturer les
neurones pour dire alors que on va
mettre un filet de sécurité ruralité bon
oui attention sauf que les communes
moyennes vont être les plus impactées
même si on nous parle tout dans la
réalité a juste titre alors bah oui donc
on trouve un machin pour que les
communes moyennes puissent se développer
oui attention mais les grands projets
nationaux eux ils sont souvent dans les
métropoles comment ont territorialise le
foncier de ces grands projets nationaux
donc on va créer des ce qui est un
comble parce que c'est
notre époque où il faut des carbonner
des usines à gaz et
et donc là dessus la simplification
renvoie à notre propre capacité à
accepter le risque voilà c'est un propos
général mais je pense que c'est la base
de tout et que le risque il vaut mieux
de temps en temps un échec il faut des
échecs que de temps en temps quelqu'un
sorte des clous à condition qu'il soit
sanctionné que vouloir tout prévoir
la norme c'est le culte et c'est une
croyance à mon avis fausse
de la planification de penser que tous
les cas de figure de la vie humaine
peuvent être anticipées
et donc ça renvoie des modes de pensée
je on a tous été formés pour planifier
pour pour créer de la règle tous
donc mon propos paraît peut-être très
naïf mais c'est les propos naïf qu'il
faut avancer les choses
parce que je crois juste voilà beaucoup
monsieur le Président pour cette
profession de foi
qui est majeur de l'efficacité qui passe
par de la simplification et que moi je
me réjouis que dans le travail que le
Sénat va faire on hisse ça au juste
niveau du dialogue qu'on a et que vous
là dessus et du dialogue qu'on nous de
manière très étroite aujourd'hui avec le
Conseil
d'État alors avant de passer la parole à
notre expert celui qui va nous guérir de
tous les mots moi j'ai une question en
lien avec un rapport qui a été fait par
Agnès canaillé Éric CAO sur les services
déconcentrés de l'État je pense
qu'effectivement on doit laisser de
l'initiative aux collectivités
l'initiative marche avec la
responsabilité
hier on a eu un exemple
dingue sur la mission relation
collectivité territoriale ou
l'Assemblée nationale à votre thing
disposition disons que les projets
DETR devaient être d'abord fléchés sur
des projets écologiques et donc il y a
aussi on a dit dans les ça veut dire
quoi ce machin et est-ce que vous êtes
déjà vu un maire vous proposez
aujourd'hui un projet d'école capacent
et puis si on a besoin d'autre y compris
pour desservir des unités de
méthanisation qui sont vertueux non mais
on arrête laissez les élus faire ça et
réponse du gouvernement non non on veut
mettre ça dans la loi parce qu'il faut
que dans la loi ça se sache que le
gouvernement défend la transition
écologique et on a passé 25 minutes
les amis
sur le sujet et après sur la liberté et
la responsabilité c'est-à-dire nous on
pense que les élus sont capables de bien
faire il y a un juge de paix qui en plus
et les lecteurs donc c'est vite mais
alors moi j'ai une vraie question pour
le président de l'Association des Maires
sur en même temps on voit bien que les
collectivités n'ont pas toute la
capacité
à
user de leur liberté pour sécuriser
leurs décisions et que on voit que
certaines collectivités petites qui
n'ont pas d'ingénierie de service
juridique
sont sécurisés entre guillemets quand il
y a un cadre qui définit la norme et
puis comme les mains je peux vous me
pardonnerez monsieur le Président mais
ayant fait partie de cette tribu avec
beaucoup de bonheur je me permets de
dire que parfois les mères
sont aussi leur complexité puisque ça
nous arrange par exemple de pouvoir
annoncer vous allez pas faire parce que
la vie de la BF il y a la norme machin
ça nous aide donc est-ce que comment on
gère le fait que le recours à la
responsabilité à la liberté excessive
qui sont je crois les meilleurs outils
ça ça peut être effectivement
les plus petites collectivités chers
amis tu as le droit à la parole
tu as déjà tout dit
tu as posé toutes les questions donc il
me reste donc l'expertise tu l'as tu
l'as déjà bien faite et puis le
président l'isnard dans ses propos
liminaires et
généraux finalement répondu à beaucoup
de questions qu'on pouvait se poser
et le temps est en compter je vais pas
être très long tout simplement pour
rappeler que effectivement la
c'est un des sujets majeurs des élus
locaux qui posent après aux élus locaux
et d'ailleurs on avait fait une sondage
dans le cadre de la délégation par CSA
et ça paraissait en tête des priorités
des élus
parce que c'est vrai que
la complexité normative est un sujet de
contrainte et qui fait que si on a
beaucoup de démission d'élus et c'est
aussi pour ça c'est en partie pour ça
parce que les élus en ont marre nos
concitoyens également parce que si on a
eu la crise des gilets jaunes en partie
aussi le problème normatif donc ça ça
génère beaucoup de mots dans notre
société et c'est pas simple de de
résoudre les problèmes parce que ça peut
comme le sapeur camembert qui ont fait
un trou pour embaucher un autre et
finalement la norme
afflue en permanence il y a le il y a le
stock qui est là on disait 400 000 il y
a 10 ans
il y avait Claude Belot qui avait fait
un rapport de la délégation on n'a
jamais fait d'ailleurs le compte
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui mais on doit
être plutôt à plus de 500 000 mais
personne n'est capable de nous le dire
moi
et c'est vrai que
[Musique]
sur le Président vous disait tout à
l'heure on est tous responsables
tous
coupables on a voulu mettre le principe
de tout à l'heure on a voulu mettre le
principe de précaution dans la
Constitution ça ça a été le début de
tous les mots et Conseil d'État
d'ailleurs tout à l'heure nous a
confirmé que c'est une réalité
on vote dans notre pays trois fois plus
de textes et que dans tous les pays
européens
47 48 50 textes par an pendant que les
autres et on est autour de 10-12 donc
plus on vote de textes plus on vote de
normes
et puis en attendant c'est c'est vrai on
est responsable aussi parce que quand on
voit tous les amendements qu'on dépose
quand sur un texte qu'on veut aller
vraiment dans le détail de tout et ben
on a on fabrique de la norme
et c'est vrai que c'est un travail
énorme de vouloir s'attaquer à ça moi on
a essayé de depuis un peu plus de 10 ans
dans la délégation puisque la
simplification a été un des sujets qu'on
a traité à l'initiative du président de
l'archet on a fait une veille sur la loi
sur l'urbanisme avec
Dominique bon on a vu que c'était
c'était pas simple l'urbanisme c'est un
sujet énorme
entre autres le sujet non le sujet on a
fait une proposition de la loi
constitutionnelle mais qui a pas été
plus loin que le Sénat pour essayer de
dire aux diminue la norme on a on enlève
deux normes pour une on
demande à ceux qui décident la norme de
la payer on arrête la surface position
européenne tout ça ça c'est des sujets
qui pourraient nous permettre de
diminuer la norme
alors moi je voulais savoir au niveau de
l'Association des maires de France
est-ce que vous avez une veille de de
sur la norme est-ce que vous avez un
comité de d'élus qui travaillent
là-dessus à thermomètre un tableau de
bord de la norme est-ce que vous parce
que ça nous permettrait de travailler en
encore plus en complémentarité et puis
sur le CNN mais vous avez tout à l'heure
évoqué
cette
ce conseil d'évaluation qui travaille
avec sous la pulsion d'un alembert de de
façon magistrale mais qui n'a pas de
moyens aucun moyen ils ont 6 sont six
personnes pour travailler sur la norme
on leur donne
les études d'impact trois quoi de jour
avant de voter le texte donc ils ont des
études
d'impacts et on leur donne les textes
trois jours avant pour on leur donne le
vendredi pour donner une réponse le
lundi c'est ce qui nous est c'est ce qui
est arrivé souvent à Lambert nous le
disait donc ils ont pas de possibilités
de travailler dans de bonnes conditions
moi je voulais savoir comment ce que
vous en pensez vous avez répondu en
partie déjà tout cela c'est un sujet qui
me passionne
ce qui doit migrer vers la mission
migration et avant je voudrais lui
permettre de
comme tous on s'interroge de manière
continue sur cette question de la
simplification qui devient
une tarte à la crème tout à fait
légitime mais malgré tout on se retrouve
dans une position assez
diabolique parce que
on est pris au propre au cœur de nos
propres contradictions on veut de la
protection mais on veut aussi essayer de
dire
de permis de construire et prend
individuellement les éléments qu'il la
composent va dire que c'est tout à fait
fondé et que ça amène quelque chose mais
on voit bien que quand c'est pris dans
son ensemble ça produit du temps du
délai et du coup donc là je prends pour
une chose très pratique mais de manière
générale je pense que ça pose le statut
de notre rapport à la liberté au risque
et la responsabilité et dans une société
qui est demande de tout imputable et qui
finit par du judiciaire
voilà je ne vois pas par quel bout on
peut prendre cette terrible continent de
la norme qui est un continent flottant
ou même titre que le plastique sur les
océans et qui ne cesse de grossir et ne
cesse d'alimenter ses propres effets et
donc à trouver sa propre autonomie
négative si je veux dire
voilà alors peut-être modestement
alors après il y a les révolutionnaires
qui préconisent tout mettre par-dessus
bord ce qui est aussi
poserait d'autres problèmes mais c'est
vrai que je rappelle je me souviens
qu'il y avait un secrétaire d'État de
secrétariat à la simplification
administrative
je me sens placé aussi vous avez cité
Thierry mondo mais voilà il suffit non
il n'y a plus personne mais c'est pas
plus mal non plus bon non mais il est
intéressant que pour supprimer un effet
administratif on crée une administration
quand même c'est aussi quand même très
révélation
mais enfin voilà donc je pense que
ça demande une prise de conscience et
auprès de chaque individu et
pouvoir locaux pour essayer de faire sa
part entre guillemets mais je ne suis
pas sûr qu'on parvienne vraiment à
obtenir
un changement profond de la tendance
lourde que l'on dénonce ici là
très bien
alors pour rebondir sur ce propos et
ensuite répondre à Monsieur le Premier
Vice-Président
il faut il faut pas il faut pas du tout
désespérer
alors il est vrai qu'ici on dansait dans
ce lieu on respecte laïcité mais ça quoi
il y a le Saint-Esprit dans cette
superbe chapelle moi je trouve que c'est
ce lieu est magnifique je l'ai découvert
pour le premier bureau de la MF post
congrès l'année dernière
ce qui était presque attribué à qui toi
non je plaisante et
mais bon je vais faire la border non
simplement le dire c'est que parce que
je pensais pendant vous écoutant je me
disais c'est souvent une métaphore qui
me vient c'est le curé qui qui fait qui
fait son homélie en disant il y a de
moins en moins de monde dans les églises
mais ceux qui sont là c'est encore ceux
qui croient quoi donc nous on il faut y
croire parce que
il faut s'adresser à ceux qui n'y
croient pas donc ce qui nous nous paraît
évident dans le constat c'est pour ça
qu'il faut porter le constat n'est pas
évident dans beaucoup de domaines de
l'action publique
euh donc il faut que ce qu'on dit ici il
faut pas se dire on se le dire on se le
répète il se passe rien non c'est pas à
cause de nous qui se passe rien c'est
parce que c'est tous les autres qui
revient en arrière je suis sûr que
autour de cette table du côté des
administrations tout le monde est par
convaincu de ce que l'on dit ou alors
ils sont ils sont naïf et puis c'est pas
comme ça que ça marche et puis et cetera
donc il faut absolument proposer ce
renversement étourdissant parce que la
liberté c'était tourissant et
effectivement il y a le la route enfin
la route de la servitude elle est pavée
de bonnes intentions et et de facilité
et de dire effectivement je suis bloqué
l'état m'a bloqué si il m'a bloqué ça on
a ce genre de d'effet la liberté c'est
étourdissant sauf que c'est la seule
façon de progresser c'est la meilleure
c'est pas abstrait la liberté c'est
c'est la seule façon d'être responsable
donc de prendre des décisions de rendre
des comptes
et notre système aujourd'hui a diluer la
prise de décision donc à diluer la
responsabilité donc en train de diluer
la démocratie et le civisme c'est très
c'est très important ce qui est en train
de se passer première
oui mais tout est lié mais la pression
médiatique c'est celle qu'on veut bien
se donner aussi enfin
tout est lié et donc pour ne pas
désespérer non pas bien en cours
simplement mais tout le pays le
puisqu'on parlait de ça tout à l'heure
mais le ce que veut dire c'est qu'il y a
quand même des endroits où on y arrive
il y a des grandes entreprises qui
avaient
colossales mondial qui ont réussi à
lutter contre leurs effets de
bureaucratie alors c'est sisif mais
c'est permanent des pays qui ont réussi
ce qui est en train d'être fait en
Allemagne et très intéressant puisqu'on
évalue au moins un tiers le nombre de
normes qui ont été supprimées de depuis
une dizaine d'années ce qui est assez
rapide avec un agenda maîtrisé et pas
par la création d'un ministère mais par
bon c'est le structeur et fédéral est
différente mais enfin ce qui les
États-Unis ont engagé des démarches très
intéressantes en la matière
on parle souvent de la Suisse mais à
juste titre
donc il y a des formes de démocratie et
passe et y compris dans les états
centraux y compris en Suède qu'un État
central
voilà donc le Canada engagé a réussi à
s'aimer donc on doit aussi avoir en
France
l'humilité et l'ambition de regarder ce
qui se fait ailleurs ce qu'on ne fait
pas assez on va dire oui mais c'est pas
pareil mais c'est jamais pareil enfin
bon il faut quand même regarder bon et
avec cette obsession de de performance
donc moi je suis convaincu que c'est
qu'une question pour le corps ça paraît
mais le courage politique et que c'est
pas si courageux que ça parce que les
effets de surburocratie tout le monde
les vit tout le monde les affronte les
entreprises les salariés les
particuliers les retraités les étudiants
tout le monde on est en train de devenir
autoburocrate par les applis numériques
on est en train c'est nous-mêmes qui
nous faisons nos opérations bancaires et
en plus on paye
et c'est compliqué ça plante sans arrêt
donc c'est une espèce de d'acceptation
donc il est temps de changer le c'est du
c'est du gramshee c'est vraiment du
combat culturel et c'est pas du tout
désespéré pour devenir de façon et
revenir à des choses plus concrètes
ce qui pose un problème démocratique
c'est que le fait que cette norme
excessive est prise à un échelon qui en
plus éloigné la délibération perceptible
donc il y a la nécessité de d'une
nouvelle décentralisation et d'une
nouvelle déconcentration et les deux
doivent
aller de paires
par exemple propose qui est plus de
service régionaux de l'État je vois pas
à quoi ça sert et je vois pas et donc
qui est des coordinations à l'échelle
régionale pourquoi pas mais on est ni
sur une entité proche ni sur une entité
éloignée avec les nouvelles régions très
souvent en plus il y a pas de sentiment
d'appartenance donc c'est
l'adréal aujourd'hui qui est
des gens très bien l'adréal il y a
quelques idéologues aussi quand même il
faut le dire mais mais oublie mais
oublions cela imaginons que tout le
monde soit objectif soit neutre etc
aujourd'hui l'adréal est un problème non
pas que les les gens de la réelle soient
des gens méchants on n'est pas là sur
des postures morales mais parce que
l'adréal a un pouvoir exorbitant
en rendant de compte à personne et et va
démentir des positions des DDT ou des
DTM et des préfets qui sont déjà
difficiles à obtenir pour des
l'architecte des monuments historiques
peut contredire ce que dit la BF moi
juste ce cas dans la Haute-Vienne et le
maire pour le coup il disait moi je me
suis engagé il engagé quasiment tout son
budget d'investissement c'est une toute
petite commune village pour refaire
l'église du village et il est planté
pour une question de gris d'évacuation
d'eau de forme de la grille d'évacuation
des eaux sur le parvis de l'église parce
que cette église apparemment a un vrai
caractère patrimonial très fort
l'architecte monument historique a aussi
son mot à dire et qui veut montrer que
sa science par rapport à la baisse ou la
BF on montre sa science par rapport je
sais pas à qui et que donc 1 partons de
principe généraux des concentration des
services de l'État il faut qu'il y a un
patron il faut qu'il y ait un
responsable des services de l'État
localement on dit le préfet pourquoi pas
c'est l'air du temps moi ça me va bien
et le sous-préfet bon mais très bien et
que les fonctionnaires de l'adresse
soient réaffectés localement et moi je
vais plus loin alors ça c'est pas une
position de l'AMF je pense que les
services de la DREAL devraient être des
services départementaux et non plus
d'État
et et là aussi ça heurte un truc oh là
là mais est-ce qu'ils seront neutres
parce qu'on a encore la foi on pense
encore que plus c'est grand plus état
plus c'est neutre et c'est pas vrai
voilà c'est
pas vrai
voilà et c'est pas tout le cas non plus
mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'à un
moment donné la neutralité
l'impartialité l'efficacité n'est pas
proportionnelle à la taille de la
structure ça il faut le dire donc moi je
suis pour la solidarité donc je suis
pour un vrai transfert réglement de
pouvoir réglementaire et ça les MF le
dit aux collectivités territoriales
deuxième et après il faudrait qu'on
apporte des choses plus précises dans
les expositions légales mais deuxième
donc la déconcentration aujourd'hui
c'est une source de complication au
quotidien très lourde très lourde et
obtenir les avis conformes des uns et
des autres quand vous avez des études
quatre saisons sans arrêt enfin c'est
n'importe quoi on oublie les finalités
des choses décentralisation bloc de
compétences
que ça qui a un vrai pouvoir
réglementaire qui soit transféré
collectivités territoriales que que la
solidarité soit une réalité concrète
donc on arrête de dire on va contracter
via moi je suis très attaché aux
affaires commun mais je suis pas attaché
au supracommunalité donc oui aux
intercommunalités non supracommunalité
comment se fait-il qu'on accepte comme
c'était une évidence que sur des
dispositifs d'aide aux communes
aujourd'hui on soit obligé dans la
réalité de passer par les
intercommunalités
RTE contre un avenir ça ça crée de la
complication non et de l'injustice et
c'est pas normal c'est tout donc
ce combat là on doit le porter par des
principes forts et ensuite les trouver
dans nos textes et ils sont ce combat
n'est pas perdu la population attend
cela regardez sur les grandes on parlait
la loi climat est résilience parce que
je dors dans le pif depuis quelques
temps
on part de donc d'une bonne intention il
faut lutter contre l'artificialisation
on prépare aussi vous êtes intervenus
récemment sur la revitalisation des
centres bourds des centres-villes etc on
a le pays qui a le plus de dispositif de
protection du petit commerce et on est
le pays qui a le faire le plus ses
petits commerces parce que un petit
commerce en moi j'étais petit commerçant
on veut pas être protégé on veut pouvoir
travailler ça n'a rien à voir si une
mentalité différente mais qui connaît le
petit commerce dans l'administration qui
personne s'est méprisé qui comprend
qu'on ne veut pas des dispositifs de
soutien on veut ne plus être pénalisé
par des distorsions fiscales on a quatre
entre 80 et 90 taxes et impôts lorsqu'on
a un petit commerce physique lorsqu'on
est un commerce numérique on en a une
quinzaine donc moi je suis pas
contre-commerce numérique je suis même
consommateur numérique mais aujourd'hui
on oriente les consommateurs le foncier
est bien plus accessible pour des
centres commerciaux et bien moins cher
que l'accès à un bail commercial dans
une ville et parce qu'on a créé on peut
faire toutes les lois qu'on veut seuil
de 3000 mètres carrés 1500 mètres carrés
10 mm². mais c'est la vie c'est pas ça
donc je voyais aujourd'hui j'ai décidé
de faire de la philosophie et non mais
c'est très important parce que je me
suis rendu compte que on va dans les
détails techniques et qu'en fait on
n'oublie pourquoi en fait les choses
vous vous donc sur le et ça me permet
aussi de rebondir sur ce que disait
Françoise tout à l'heure donc monsieur
le Président décentralisation
déconcentration
soyons capables et le CV engage une
démarche sur l'autorité de du président
Larcher de faire des propositions
simples sur la décentralisation qui
prévoit pas tous les cas de figure qui
laisse vous dire tout à l'heure il faut
donner plus d'initiative je trouve cette
phrase à la fois juste et effrayante
comment on en est arrivé à un point à se
dire il faut se donner plus d'initiative
mais non mais c'est l'inverse moi j'ai
connu il y a 20 ans d'années lorsqu'on
faisait un projet on analysait ce qui
était interdit
maintenant on recherche ce qui est
autorisé
voilà le renversement donc quand on
parle de dernier on l'a déjà eu cette
discussion France on dit le dernier
kilomètre mais non on est le premier
kilomètre de l'action publique on n'est
pas le dernier qui va mettre toutes ces
formulations sont très significatives
très significatifs donc c'est un combat
culturel amené avant tout et ensuite on
a traduit voilà on traduit sur le plan
législatif et médiatiquement répondre à
quand il y a un fait divers on est
capable de dire écoutez il y a une
charge émotionnelle très forte
il va falloir analyser ce fait divers
mais ne nous jetons pas sur une
législation supplémentaire parce qu'il y
a un fait divers je crois qu'on est
capable de dire ça sur une chaîne d'info
et qu'une majorité silencieuse le
comprend
il faut remettre la raison au cœur du
débat politique et donc
ce que vous évoquez tout à l'heure le
gouvernement qui dit il faut que ce soit
dans la loi mais combattons-le le
théâtre politique le théâtre politique
donc une émotion ou un grand truc donc
et donc il faut l'inscrire dans la loi
ben non non
l'efficacité de l'action c'est pas
forcément une disposition législative
quoi
mais oui mais
on alimente tout de même climat est
résilience au lieu de dire au lieu
climat résilience très simple il faut
dire sur il faut des absolument
décarboné très vite notre activité
humaine ça c'est un objectif majeur
d'ordre public
du terme on doit valoriser les
externalités négatives du carbone ce
qu'on tourne autour de ça avec la taxe
carbone et tout et c'est plutôt
pertinent la réflexion on doit donner
une valeur quand je dis valoriser c'est
donner une valeur
et ensuite plutôt que de dire un chef
d'entreprise quelqu'un aujourd'hui par
la loi c'est-à-dire faire une loi non
plus d'objectifs mais une loi de
modalités nos lois ne doivent être que
des lois d'objectif et redonner de
l'autorité à l'état pour sanctionner la
non atteinte des objectifs et de dire
plutôt que de dire à chaque entreprise
vous avez une activité ce que j'ai
rencontré ça dans la croix alimentaire
pas dans la distribution alimentaire
vous avez un entrepôt de stockage donc
des grossistes de produits alimentaires
qui m'ont alerté notamment produit
italien je connais donc des chambres
froides des machins aujourd'hui on leur
dit pas vous devez en 2025 est à tel
objectif de décarbonation par rapport au
volume de votre entrepôt ou votre je
sais pas les critères et puis en 2030 à
temps et puis en 2040 à temps ça
commence à être dit mais on leur dit non
vous devez végétaliser le toit de votre
entrepôt je ne caricature pas
et quand la puissance publique se
substitue aux individus pour
l'allocation des ressources
et bien là on est dans un système de
collectivisation qui ne fonctionne pas
ça ne marche pas et on crée des effets
donc le chef d'entreprise au lieu de
dire je vais sauver mon résultat net
faire du résultat donc m'occuper de mes
clients m'occuper de mes salariés
m'occuper de mes fournisseurs et
atteindre cet objectif de décarbonation
parce que beaucoup de parce que c'est la
loi et puis parce que je suis sensible à
ça et je vais plutôt changer je vais
créer une unité de production
énergétique en mettant une éolienne sur
mon toit en mettant des panneaux
solaires et et en faisant en changeant
l'isolation dans le bâtiment il dit ah
ben non il recherche la truc il appelle
l'adréal quand il arrive à trouver il
appelle le service machin et à la fin on
lui dit ben non là il faut végétaliser
là il faut faire ci mais c'est absurde
donc
déjà il faut poser ce diagnostic là il
faut revoir les textes et
et refuser la théâtralisation de de de
la vie politique par des effets
d'affichage qui sont
puis ils sont emphatiques puis ils sont
exagérés grandiloquents plus moins ils
sont puissants et effectivement et ça
aussi ça alimente ensuite la capacité
d'être libre
parce que c'était la question comment
c'est bien beau dire ouais c'est une
question d'abord je répète beaucoup de
gens le syndrome de la servitude
volontaire c'est facile c'est facile
aussi de s'infantiliser d'accepter son
infantilisation de dire c'est pas moi
c'est l'autre
et ça nécessite deux moyens l'ingénierie
et l'argent
tant qu'on continuera de titaliser
les collectivités territoriales et comme
et que l'autorité de tutelle est une
autorité surendettée et mallégurée qui
s'appelle l'Etat qui emprunte pour son
fonctionnement ce qui est interdit dans
la collectivité territoriale
il y aura forcément la tentation
régulière de piocher dans les ressources
de cette utilisation c'est les dotation
voilà il y en a plein dedans et donc là
ok on va le remplacer la CVAE après
avoir fait la taxe d'habitation en
parfait la taille professionnelle vous
vous allez promis juré ça sera à
l'Europe mais quel euros de quelle heure
on parle d'un euro constant dans nos
courants on le voit bien que la nexation
de quoi on parle et puis c'est pas vrai
sur la taxe d'habitation bientôt on sera
en mesure de vous de vous de vous dire
que il nous manque au moins un milliard
sur la compensation
au moins un milliard on est en train
d'évaluer avec André Le Niel et le
Comité des finances locales on fera ça
donc
la liberté
sans pain l'être humain n'est pas libre
c'est une paraphrase de truc de cabus je
veux dire c'est que à un moment donné il
faut la responsabilité financière
et ça sera un lien civique donc la
réforme des finances des collectivités
territoriales elle est incontournable
pour simplifier
incontournable et en plus ça motivera
les gens il en tient lui attends si plus
personne ne peut d'impôts sauf les
propriétaires qu'on fait culpabiliser
vous passez votre vie à quémander et
nous-mêmes mères on quémande de l'argent
de l'État qui est censé nous appartenir
mais nous on veut pas être des
quémandeurs on peut être des pleurnichas
moi je veux rendre des comptes sur ma
politique fiscale mais c'est quoi ma
politique fiscale aujourd'hui à part le
foncier bâti
c'est quoi ma poésie fiscale donc vous
ne simplifierez pas nous simplifierons
pas si on ne recréer pas l'acceptation
fiscale et la responsabilité fiscale
deuxièmement l'ingénierie
comme on a perdu des moyens financiers
les beaucoup de mérides communautés de
communes non plus d'ingénierie
administrative et comme on complique
l'accès aux politiques publiques parle
la culture des appels à projets des
appels à manifestation d'intérêt non
seulement on alourdi mais on enrichit
des cabinets de conseils qui sont qui
interviennent dans un assistance à
maîtrise d'ouvrage et qui vous aide à
décrypter les appels à projets et y
répondre mais en plus vous empêchez
nombre de communauté de communes et de
communes rurales d'avoir accès donc vous
amplifier
la fracture territoriale donc
l'ingénierie le serema est une réponse
nous on pousse beaucoup pour que le
serrer ma soit bien reconnu mais je
pense qu'on peut avoir des guichets
d'ingénierie avec là aussi avec les
départements dont on s'est aperçu que
ils étaient et
les intercommunalités de faire des
guichets d'ingénierie pour permettre à
la solidarité d'être communale d'être
une réalité
sur le tableau de bord on n'a pas de
tableau de bord parce que moi je sais
que pour analyser ça j'ai une démarche à
la fois déductive à inductive déductif
je regarde le nombre de mots Dallos ou
allergie France et c'est comme ça qu'on
voit que sur le code de l'environnement
c'est facile multiplié par 10 en disant
et donc on voit le nombre de mots et qui
et deuxième et ensuite la prochaine
utile on lance à l'AMF parce qu'on veut
faire de la lutte contre la bureaucratie
l'un des piliers de notre action et on
veut vraiment faire les choses de pas ça
dénoncer parce que c'est ce qui permet
politiquement de faire passer les choses
et c'est ce qui permet d'accrocher
l'opinion pour reprendre sur le
populisme etc il faut dénoncer mais
ensuite il faut proposer et nous-mêmes
on fait de la bureaucratie dans nos
collectivités
et donc là dessus on va on va lancer une
approche inductive pour faire remonter
parce que à chaque fois je vais dans un
appartement on me raconte des histoires
abracadabrantesque j'arrive à le dire et
et c'est un travail c'est un travail et
et qui sont et qui sont réels qui sont
pas des trucs qui sont pas des
inventions mythomaniaques de mer donc je
voudrais qu'on fasse une sorte de sur le
numérique qui est en faire un bouquin
après une sorte de livre noir mais pas
de proposer parce que à travers ces
exemples il faut qu'on remonte par
l'exemple à l'absurdité de la règle à
l'injonction contradictoire on parlait
d'urbanisme c'est une somme d'ajonction
contradictoire et qui crée de la
sécurité juridique et qui fait qu'à la
fin en plus soit tu acceptes l'inertie
soit tu prends des risques et tu peux te
retrouver en BT judiciairement voire
pénalement sans savoir pourquoi ou parce
que tout simplement on a voulu agir
donc on va il faut proposer cette cette
évolution
c'est pas une révolution parce que je
parle révolutionnariste mais cette
évolution copernicienne voilà qui
ressemble à une révolution
mais et là-dessus on va faire cet
observatoire et si on peut le travailler
ensemble moi je suis très preneur
je l'ai trouvé très réjouissant ce coloc
et je trouve que la position du Conseil
d'État est très intéressante et très
positive et très encourageante c'est
pour ça que tout n'est pas foutu
alors vous avez vu les plus motivés
aussi sur ce
président
de la délégation faire un travail un peu
considérable si je veux dire de
contamination des esprits autour de ça
qui en fait une révolution
copernicienne je partage totalement ça
chère Dominique
vous aviez des questions
on est désolé mais alors il y a une
grande qualité ici ce matin comme
d'habitude la quantité est un peu moins
parce que on fait du PLF enfin si c'est
un peu comme les Galeries Lafayette en
ce moment avec le père alors chers
Dominique donc très rapidement merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président vous avez pas évoqué la
question du droit à l'expérimentation et
de la différenciation est-ce que ça peut
pas être aussi des moyens pour justement
arriver à simplifier directement sur les
territoires alors je sais que la
différenciation parfois elle heurte y
compris des élus parce qu'en disant la
loi quand même c'est un cadre général
qui s'applique pour tous et comment
est-ce qu'on arrive à pouvoir garder
donc c'est quand même des sujets qu'on
voit souvent poivre et de plus en plus
quand même
souvent aussi ce droit à
l’expérimentation donc quel est votre
votre approche de ces sujets et
simplement par exemple par rapport au
droit de l'urbanisme la difficulté du
droit de l'urbanisme qui est devenue
extrêmement complexe et instable est-ce
que c'est aussi parce que on voit bien
que de plus en plus ce sont les enjeux
environnementaux qui prennent une place
prépondérante loin de moi le fait de
dire qu'il ne faut pas les prendre en
compte mais quand on voit dans les
objectifs du Code de l'Urbanisme
aujourd'hui
il y a des objectifs qui sont supplantés
par l'objectif environnemental et qui
entraîne de fait cette supériorité de
l'objectif environnemental au regard des
autres objectifs qui ont été mis dans le
code de l'urbanisme qui n'a cessé
d'enfler au fur et à mesure depuis 1983
et qui aujourd'hui peut-être génère
aussi cette complexité et
ce risque que
et de plus en plus instable parce qu'on
le remet sans arrêt sur le métier
de très bonnes questions c'est d'être ça
se féminisme je crois madame le sénateur
même le sénatrice
simple
non sur l'urbanisme
la solution
elle est je vais utiliser un mot qui va
être très provocateur elle est libérale
voilà je j'ose le terme et elle revient
sur ce que je disais sur le climat
résilient c'est-à-dire que on doit avoir
il faut valoriser ce que l'on veut en
termes d'objectif de politique publique
y compris environnementale qui est une
priorité aujourd'hui et faire des bonus
malus très dissuasif et encourageant ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
problème du droit de l'urbanisme c'est
que il a il est le
l'expression de l'injonction
contradictoire l'expression on doit
mieux protéger les sols mais on doit
fournir des logements on doit créer des
écoles mais on doit pas artificialiser
on doit regarder quand le COS a été
supprimé
il y a eu des infections totalement
contradictoires sur la notion de
coefficient d'utilisation sociale que je
trouve était pertinente qui était
finalement très innovante très ancienne
pour un rapport entre le bâti et
l'emprise foncière et aujourd'hui au
lieu de de
faire une loi qui m'a résilience qui
donne un objectif national qui nous
tombe sur la tête et qui va passer par
des machins où on va une fois de plus
essayer de priver les maires de leur
responsabilité d'urbanisme et il est
acceptable qui tutelle d'une autre
collectivité
sur le pouvoir de risque des mers je
vous le dis qui est des objectifs
territorialisés à l'échelle de région
pourquoi pas puis c'est la bonne échelle
moi je pense que c'est la bonne chaîne
c'est les bassins de vie télescope mais
pourquoi pas mais ça doit pas être par
une collectivité ça doit être par le
conseil des maires de la région quoi
c'est une question fondamentale
indépendamment des personnalités des
autres c'est d'ailleurs la présidente de
rayon de France elle est d'accord
demande pas à s'occuper en tout cas elle
à s'occuper de l'urbanisme des communes
bon
et donc sur l'urbanisme on a eu entre
les lois
SRU élan allure et tout icanti un
certain nombre de textes qui qui ont été
des textes d'affichage mais qui font
qu'aujourd'hui c'est incompréhensible
voilà donc quels sont les objectifs de
l'urbanisme c'est d'avoir un de répondre
à des fonctionnalités de base que sont
le logement les services publics
l'économie et notamment la
l'initialisation de de le faire de façon
décarbonée et en préservant la
biodiversité il n'y a pas de tiercé dans
l'ordre c'est et 3 de préserver et de
valoriser les paysages parce que c'est
important les paysages c'est pas voilà
la poésie des paysages on peut pas être
défendre l'environnement et vouloir
aller dire les paysages donc à partir de
ces objectifs
revoyant la fiscalité je reviens
là-dessus aujourd'hui je suis pas plus
incité à
en nous permettrait on entend parler
depuis 30 ans de la ville sur la ville
moi j'ai entendu des Colocs la ville sur
la ville il y a 30 ans par la ville sur
la ville maintenant c'est la résilience
chaque mois et la transition chaque mois
sont chaque époque à ces mots mais pour
qu'il y ait la ville sur la ville si le
maire d'A intérêt à signer des permis
que pour des HLM et des résidences
secondaires et que en termes et qu'il ne
touche pas d'impôts résidentiel
quel est l'intérêt quelle est la
motivation si on vous supprime la CVAE
et il faut une fiscalité économique
compétitive moi je dis que l'État
commence par supprimer la C3S qui
étaient un vrai un peu de production lui
je vous enseignerai
j'ai suivi ça de jour et nuit même et et
donc sur le donc de supprimer mais mais
si on a plus d'intérêt direct avec une
liberté de taux de une émulation une
compétition moi j'ose le terme aussi
entre on sera pas dans la performance on
va pas rien industrialiser donc sur
l'urbanisme tout ça est lié c'est à dire
que à un moment donné il faut on devrait
lorsque l'on fait une verticalité
et ensuite on en assume le risque
politique mais mais on y arrive
localement on arrive on se réunit on
discute avec les habitants on a juste
les mères c'est un habitant parmi les
habitants comme on est comme on est
proche on est responsable physiquement
et puis si les gens des mauvais mères ça
leur problème il faut qu'ils changent
enfin ça doit citer les gens à s'engager
dans la vie municipale mais
on devrait avoir une valorisation
financière
lorsqu'on fait une belle verticalité
c'est tout et ça serait bien plus
efficace que tous les machins qui
veulent interdire l'artificialisation
et une pénalisation lorsqu'on
artificialise de façon désordonnée on
arriverait à traduire ça en grand
objectif de politique publique ça c'est
une approche qui intellectuellement pas
au sens dévoyé du terme depuis les
libéral au sens du 19e de
responsabilisation d'intérêt et sur la
différenciation et le et
l'expérimentation alors il y a eu
la l'opposition de certains élus en
disant la différenciation se va à
l'encontre ce que tu évoqué à l'encontre
ce que vous étiez à l'encontre une
vision égalitaire de des choses moi j'ai
une réticence qui est tout à fait
inverse je trouve que donc un petit
contre-pied je trouve surréaliste qu'on
soit obligé
d'imaginer qu'il faille inscrire dans la
loi voir dans la Constitution le
principe qui est la base de la vie c'est
que tout n'est pas pareil
je trouve ça délirant alors je sais que
ça part d'une bonne intention et comme
notamment d'amis politiques on va faire
la différenciation de l'expérimentation
mais quand on en est au point de
demander un droit à la différenciation à
l'expérimentation ça veut dire qu'on a
plus le pouvoir de la décision moi je
veux le pouvoir de la décision et la
décision elle est pas l'unité de la
nation ce n'est pas l'uniformité de la
nation l'égalité tarisme détruit la
justice ça renvoie d'autres débats y
compris sur l'éducation la carte
scolaire etc on a signé à résidence il y
a rien de plus injuste que le système
soviétique que le centralisme
démocratique voilà je suis
volontairement provocateur et donc
l'application de la loi par définition
la loi c'est la même pour tous
et la loi s'applique correspond à des
cas de figure tous différents ça ne veut
pas dire donc être obligé de faire
valoir un principe de différenciation ça
veut dire qu'on a un niveau de
centralisme de bureaucratisme de de
collectivisation qui est complètement
dingue et c'est le nœud gordien c'est
pour ça qu'on paye plus d'impôts et de
charges qu'ailleurs et qu'à la fin d'un
mois de service public sur le terrain
avec les fonctionnaires sont moins bien
payés qu'ailleurs c'est cette surcharge
mais enfin moi c'est tout mon discours
tout mon propos tout le monde engagement
toute ma motivation donc je suis
réticent sur ces principes là
individuellement je parle pas dans les
MF là parce qu'on n'a pas délibéré
là-dessus non pas parce que je crains
que ça aille à l'encontre de la d'un des
trois valeurs de la devise républicaine
quelle est l'égalité mais parce que ça
va à l'encontre
ça traduit ça va pas le droit mais ça
traduit l'impasse dans laquelle on est
arrivé à dire enfin je suis désolé la
loi est la même sur la taxe le foncier
bâti mais tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes taux de fonciers bâti en France
est-ce que c'est grave au contraire
c'est bien et puis ça renvoie et quand
quelqu'un la diminue quelqu'un
l'augmente il y a un débat local ça fait
polémique ou pas c'est ça la vie donc je
suis très sceptique sur ce concept-là
très sceptique et je pense qu'en fait
c'est une façon d'ajouter de la
complication plus parce que et je
termine là-dessus parce que j'ai compris
que j'étais à la bourre et vous aussi à
cause de moi mais enfin c'est à cause
des questions mais non mais
l'expérimentation dans la réalité ça
paraît du bon sens on dirait on va
expérimenter sauf que ça veut dire que
tu as pas le droit de décider pourquoi
il faut qu'on m'explique et deux pour
obtenir le droit expérimenté ça signifie
qu'il y a une procédure en plus
pour obtenir la fameuse dérogation la
fameuse expérimentation donc ça va fait
l'objet de process qui eux-mêmes
nécessite de l'ingénierie et on retourne
dans la spirale de la complication donc
je crains dans la réalité c'est concepts
là ne se traduisent par des couches
supplémentaires sédimentaires de de
bureaucratie et d'administration et ça
vous alerte dans cette maison qui
réfléchit beaucoup à ces concepts
j'avais apporté si monsieur le Président
merci beaucoup de votre
détermination et de voilà de notre
travail
ensemble merci on apprécie beaucoup et
je remercie Charlotte qui est un lien
exceptionnel entre nous donc vous avez
un gage monsieur le Président qui va
être celui de faire une photo avec nous
voilà
milles merci Monsieur prise d'enchères
David et puis hier il y a eu comment
dire un gouvernement d'union nationale
ici au Sénat su en faveur des communes
nouvelles
et que nous nous invitons monsieur le
Président
allait comme dire
porter ça insister capitaliser sur ce
que nous avons fait pour que nous
puissions gagner parce que encore une
fois il s'est un peu le sens de ce que
vous disiez les fonctionnaires nous
expliquent que c'est pas possible machin
et en même temps chez la première
ministre on nous a bien dit que ils
allaient essayer de lever
le manque d'imagination des
fonctionnaires voilà donc
le président en amour sans imagination
l'amour n'a aucune chance
c'est dans je crois que c'est dans le
quart de femme c'est comment politique
sans imagination la politique n'a aucune
chance voilà
allez on y va merci